this show is brought to you by the cash
app what accident even is that kind of
country we gotta Southern this is the
number one Finance on the app store
you know the cash app is the simplest
way to send and receive money especially
when your friends o you money all my
friends or when you owe them none of my
friends you use the cash up ideal I use
the cash cart every time I go to the
Starbucks cuz you save really yeah it's
one of the booths any coffee shop so you
go and you buy coffee and you you save
get like a discount
basically yeah it says like you've said
coffee dollars four dollars instead of
nine dollars it's less than that but if
you get a nice coffee and I think I
think of dollars 69 it's what it takes
off no wonder you're buying these coffee
so much so be wrong but I think I'm
right
cash up is the easiest way to try and
grow your money in the stock market with
their investing fat cha with the cash
app you can instantly invest in any
stock for as little as $1 get really
cool pretty impressive
did you know the brokerage services are
provided by Cash Shop investing a
subsidiary of square and member si PC I
did not well you did because it's
written here but I see what you mean I
didn't you know until you tell me ad
when you design it for cash app and use
the promo code Whitney not only when you
instantly receive $10 but cash up will
also donate $10 to as a privy project
that was weird I kind of bailed halfway
through yeah but you meant what you
manage the trevor project an amazing
organization that provides protective
services to the LGBTQ youth across
america
don't forget the promo code whitney when
you download cash out now Brogan Whitney
Julia Whitney we're happy Thursday
it's Thursday Benton's dressed like a
pink lady from Greece I was and I'm on
it I'm all over this I like what's
happening and I'm dressed like a
divorced lady from the 80s she's way
cooler I feel awkward because I've been
computer in front of me right now
because I could not get this freaking
document to print has a printer ever
worked has anyone's printer ever worked
mine always work
Morgause every time always works for me
it never works for me you press print
and then you got to put the printer on
can someone just make a printer that
just you press print and then the thing
comes out that you're trying to print I
really think you need to update your
computer I truly believe that with all
my heart I don't think that's what it is
I think it is as soon as I update it
then it's gonna run out of toner and as
soon as it runs out of toner to run I
think it's always something with the
fucking printer
I shouldn't be printing paper anyway I
guess anyway so I have to look at my
computer from that's the point you
shouldn't be a printing you know what I
mean that I think that's the bigger
issue I didn't think about that
okay so couple of Nelson Moss we keep
forgetting to make announcements at the
end of the show we kind of go out very
abruptly but blaze the glory text me if
you want to send us ideas for where to
go on the tour we're not going to the
lemur center because we're not going to
Miami been getting a lot of really good
ideas though for Miami for just when we
go in there and avoid general and good
idea
we should you go there for just our
vacation at the end of the tour but keep
texting us what is it eight one eight
two three nine seven five to seven fuck
memorize that you know what they call
that digital amnesia that's a real thing
that's a real thing on the book that I
read over the break because we outsource
so much stuff to our phones that we now
don't actually remember things as well
okay yeah I believe that I do percent I
only know my parents number I don't know
your phone number I know my parents
phone number and I know the security
code on your credit card thing I know
something I've memorized this is
alarming you know my credit card number
and the security code and
know that assistants can get booked
that's it I do know that you know that
they can sue their bosses for overtime I
don't think it works none of this is
good I've never seen it to follow
through you might have to borrow money
for me to sue me though lawyers take
credit cards I don't even know I'm sure
they do
they love layaway can you put a lawyer
on layaway is lame I still think I don't
know I was thinking that it's really
good for people I believe in the what
was that you would say like hail I can
give you 10 bucks now for this sparkly
tube top yeah well I think people did it
more for Christmas for their kids and
stuff like where I'm friendly people
would put all their toys on layaway and
pay them off for a Christmas tree
layaway people would be so sweet people
would show up and like you would pay off
someone fly away without their knowing
and they would show up and they'll get
paid off when I see videos like that it
makes me wanna cry
yeah that's such a nice thing the singer
SIA did that member she went to the
grocery store over the break and your
toy store and opponents of her made me
cry I like stuff like that anyway so I
have a computer in front of me for those
that are watching on YouTube but most of
you aren't a lot of people are telling
us that when we talk about something we
need to describe it but you should watch
on YouTube too cuz it's very fun I don't
know I think people like to listen to
this in their car you can do both yeah
to double experience just soothing oh
I'd like to set an intention for myself
for this podcast which is to talk slower
and to not say like some of my life
intention so excited because I was
realizing the podcast and you know how
you can do a one like you can speed up
some podcast listening to it I thought
it was fed up but that was just about as
we talk you're welcome
I like that it's a race but I would
absorb this but quick so if I say like
too much I want to wear like a
shot-caller for what not caught like
collar
how do you pronounce it Chuck who's an
expert on a shot-caller a shock yes for
when I say like I want you to start
electrocuting me I'm not even kidding I
say it too much okay oh yeah the tech
and I want to stop doing this so much
it's gross its disgusting I get it I'm
hydrated obviously are you doing that I
don't notice I mean oh gosh when I talk
I'm like um um Dave is not basically
alright guys let me tell you guys that
guys
that's how I'd hate that we're sorry I
sound to myself it's it makes me cringe
it's like hey guys I'm like fast I sound
like an Connelly going through puberty
makes me feel better
my voice you do sometimes skip
consonants and words yeah I do
constantly feel like I'm going to
puberty
I can't tell if you're talking -
raspberries love that man Beach
impediment mix with my list forever
puberty eternal boobs my fragrance now
at Nordstrom's eight one eight two three
nine seven five two seven I don't get
your tour ticket get your tour tickets
and when you text me don't be a dork
dude don't I'm watching a lot of people
going to complete emotional spirals when
they text me if I don't respond in a day
I'll try to get to you but it's so funny
when I open someone's text and I just
see this internal battle they've had
with themselves over the past couple
days trying to get in touch with me
it'll start out with like anyway needs
such a big fan and love you so so so
much I love you you're probably not even
reading this you're too busy and then
like three hours later the bag is this
wait is this like an assistant and then
like three hours later the book okay
this probably isn't you anyway love you
the next day it'll be like you know what
fuck you this is a scam that you're
mining my data fuck you fuck your robot
fuck Benton like they go on like a total
diatribe at me and then I'm like hey you
okay it's some of the technician my mom
since the same person at this point I'm
sorry it's a ok people seem to really
like the word of the pod word of the day
we're to the pod what's our word to make
you sound smart at a party today
Benton um Uncas anxious which is
excessively
or integration ously flattering and also
oily that is a confusing definition
unctuous basically means your kiss-ass
it means you're a sucky uppy kissy asses
so if someone is being unctuous they're
probably leaving comments on celebrities
instagrams because I love you so much
for approval or favor that's right if
you really are obsessed with someone in
love
your stalker you're allowed to do that
if it's sincere this implies that it's
insincere yeah this implies you want
them to listen to your mix tape or read
your script Oh God give me a mix taking
a mix tape at coffee being the other day
I was like oh it's like in a plastic bag
it's like where do you expect me to
listen to this also I'm not in the music
business what do you think I'm gonna do
with this
you are unctuous if you're a sycophant
that's another word that is affiliated
with I'm sure this is a great word which
I'm gonna play this so that you guys can
understand because I would say it wrong
look sycophant sick of fan is like a
Starfucker
yeah I like these words because it's a
great way to attack someone verbally or
judge them and sound smarter than them
as a person who acts very lovey-dovey to
him only important people that's right
it's someone who sucks up to power it's
basically a stand-in for star fucker
yeah brown-noser
but sometimes when you call some yeah
what that was always so I am such a
visual person when I think brown-noser I
think shit no that's what it mean isn't
that what it means that's what you
should think it's too crazy word that me
to say that you're good you got your hat
there at I know but I picked your shit
on someone's nose and it grows me out
well now it's just very millennial it's
such a gross word but I think that a lot
of times when we insult other people we
end up sounding stupid ourselves when
someone think you're such a star fucker
it's like that's not intelligent I know
you ever what am i just yeah totally
sticks and stones like it's a childish
way to describe somebody so I think I'm
sure this is a good one instead of being
like that person is so fake and that
person so stupid and so obsessed like
it's just like you can also call moilee
at the same time well yeah I don't
really know what that means besides my
face like your oil your slimy you're
like they're trying to sell me something
yeah that makes that's the cup that's
like a old western tournament right
oh he's an oily man out there that's
point yeah Clint Eastwood would college
emesis and one of his movies is an oily
snake that one taking money from the
bank that oil in one yeah pretty much
oily is a compliment as far as I'm
concerned than you use to describe me
very very frequently and my skin's okay
so that's our word we're gonna try to
work it in let's started working in both
of them I'm ready
okay um see you are not unctuous I would
argue that's what I love about that I
wish I was no he will tell you exactly
what it means he will meet you say
exactly you know mean what you say say
what you mean but don't say it mean
that's all that's our home huh say what
you mean mean what you say and don't say
it mean how about that oh you know what
write that down everyone sometimes you
get silent I get impressed very
impressed that's something I would put
on my mirror in the morning and be like
you know what say what you mean mean
what you say but don't be mean
don't say it mean don't say it means
okay you can be mean it's very southern
asshole but did you know sound nice yeah
just be passive-aggressive it's much
easier way to go through life all right
everyone has been asking questions we're
gonna dedicate this open to a couple
questions you guys have for Matt and
Amma answer them how about that all
right what are they what are some got
you just picked some good ones Lindsay
asked is taking a vacation by yourself
acceptable it's the only way there is a
vacation what are you talking about I
accept for but I also think that life is
better with people certain people not
all people I didn't say in fact you're
not just any people yeah don't go on
vacation with your Nemus I I don't know
I think that vacations are better alone
unless it's with someone that really
understands your vacation style you
should bring the person who you can sit
quietly with that's right that's right
but also you don't want to go on
vacation with me I don't come out of the
room till like 6:15 that's great for an
hour and that's it
I like vacations where you can do your
thing they can do their thing thing you
meet up some that's exactly right you
have to pair with someone has the same
vacation I'm not I'm not one of those I
can't when you go on vacation and
someone's like the clipboard person
who's like the camp counselor who's you
know we're gonna go pet the stingrays
and we're gonna go release the turtles
into the ocean and then we're gonna go
do this thing I'm ready to go for a hike
and then we're gonna go plant some seeds
but devil's advocate those are sometimes
the people that will get you to do so
that you would have never done also I'm
fine with that
yeah I may not meet you but I'm just
saying something at this point in my
life there's a reason I haven't done it
because I didn't want to do you're busy
yeah cuz you didn't want also I can't
why would you go do it's like four
hundred dollars to go pedestal
I want to do that I don't I do not like
vacationing with people because I spend
the entire time adding up how much money
they've spent on the minibar and it's
all I can think about if someone takes
something out of the minibar it ruins my
whole trip really your whole trip my
whole trip it's all I think about if
someone opens that minibar and takes out
a bag of nuts that cause to art can it's
always like I can't oh that would be me
I'm like how we just ate we just spent
$40 at the buffet all-you-can-eat buffet
how did you not put a roll in your purse
and bring it up pity it's the drinks
that always get me I'm like why I need
this I need this read you don't need
that for $8 yeah you know I'm on
vacation I have any dollar nope
ruins my whole vacation on vacation all
I do is add up what everything costs
while I'm there so if someone's so when
someone pulls candy out of the minibar
oh my god it drives me nuts this is a
mental illness because look Twizzlers
Twizzlers are delicious when there are
three dollars when they're ten dollars
they're disgusting they're not a ten
dollar candy they're a three dollar
candy I can't think of a ten dollar
candy mmm I can well like you know what
and I also it makes you realize when
you're on vacation
how disgusting nuts are because nuts are
good when they're free they're not good
when you pay for that I don't think
they're good really ever I'm not like oh
there's a bowl of nuts I can have it
suspecting nuts are good when they're
maybe laced with some some salty powdery
stuff or some Chuck we have in our green
room here at our podcast
chocolate-covered almonds cashews a
shock but they had a were covered in
something nope I don't like I'm not a
vacation person I also I hate sand truth
me too I don't like I'm not a beach
person Anitra not a beach person I like
it's so sand is so gross like if you I
still have sand inside me from a trip
four years ago it's glass now when I see
someone on vacation on the beach and
they're like I'm on TV trying to make
you jealous
I've never tell us I'm like I'd rather
sit in traffic without sand inside my
butthole then be you in st. Lucas that's
not even a place it should be I don't
think is even an island having sand up
and all your crevices I don't like the
beach either but I will go if I'm going
want to go like I'm not gonna be like
that person he's like new look I'll go
then you know but I don't want to like
it's not like never my choice to go to a
beach the beach is fun for like 20
minutes and then you're either freezing
or covered in sand moist stuffs like it
ah nothing you know I'm such a
perfectionist that the beach is my
nightmare because you know when you try
to put your beach towel down without
trying to get sand on it yeah I mean
yeah you got to put a shoe on each
corner it's like whack-a-mole you got to
put a shoe on each and then some asshole
walks on your fucking towel
you made the beach down fine so annoying
for someone who is like has control it
see I think I would like a nighttime
beach with like a fire that'd be cool
that's nice you got to bring a blanket
though Laguna Beach I don't like sand
although you know that we are running
out of sand I did the world is running
on his hands who knew you could do that
until I guess dude it's like a big
problem dude we're running out of sand
what are we not running out of though
that's a really good point negative
comments no dude it is while we are
running out of sand I got really into
this because you know sand isn't
everything I don't even know this Sam is
in concrete it's in cement it's in
everything and we're running out of it
and I was fascinated by the fact that
sand mining is a whole there's a whole
black market for sand in India and they
send people down to illegally get sand
they drowned and like they are totally
unaccounted for it's as crazy sand mafia
in India I'm pretty obsessed he makes
and though it takes twenty five thousand
years for sand we can expand faster than
that I don't know I got a dog about
quicksand running under that cuz that's
pretty cool is truly the only thing that
scares me that's the only cares you
think where do you think you're gonna
come in contact with you know me what
else am I scared of what am I scared of
um my new details that's true no I love
my new details I'm scared of them being
wrong yeah what am I scared of you've
known me for a year what scares me um I
think you're scared of intimacy
I just think imperfections yeah I think
you're just scared of your own islands
your own mind really if that's true you
making up scenarios that are not gonna
happen
and then my catastrophic thing
yes I do do that but that is also more
come and then you would think I rather
we could talk about zodiac signs I would
tell you it's a very vertical view it's
very Virgo but I feel like everything is
every sign that's why they're all
different because they're the same and
that's important in science I read this
book over the break called irresistible
I'm reading it now yes I've been telling
everybody about this book and there is
an experiment where they put a bunch of
people in a room for 20 minutes okay
hooked up to something that would give
you an electric shock but they said you
do not have to shock yourself this is
just not and they made up some like lie
of why it was there and they were like
if you press this button it will shock
you it'll be like a like a hard pinch
it'll feel like a syringe needle going
into your skin you don't have to do it
we're just needing to be him for 20
minutes and we want to know what you
think about in that 20 minutes 60% of
the people shocked themselves one person
did it 190 times it was they were doing
a study basically on if people can be
alone with their own thoughts and they
found that people would rather be in
physical pain than alone with their own
thoughts you know it's very interesting
this the book I don't know if I
mentioned the book is called
irresistible by the way yeah what about
the study in there where they put the
people in the room with a phone and they
have them have a conversation and some
people have a phone in the room with
them and some people have a notepad and
they were saying that just having a
phone in the room makes your connection
in your conversation worse even if you
never touch it Oh makes you dumber yay -
it said that you have a phone in your
headless Impa theater Oh God talking to
me and I I don't know I don't even know
if I believe that or not but it's not
science you have to do you mean it's
science it's just a quiz that's a whole
thing about science is you kinda have to
believe it unlike pseudoscience which is
my favorite thing to believe okay so yes
it is okay to go on vacation alone I
actually argue it's the best way to go
on vacation the most bang for your buck
but go out and enjoy that sand while we
still have it because we are running out
of sand this podcast is good for you I'm
teaching all kinds of things that you're
gonna be able to talk about at parties
and sound smart so I agree it's totally
okay to go to a party and just talk be
like oh did you guys know we were
running out of
and you'll be the hit or you'll make no
friends and then you'll have to go on
vacation longer
dude that's why there were floods in
Houston because of the sand mining in
the rivers it's causing a whole problem
it's a real saga and they're trying you
can't get sand from deserts because the
grains are too round or something they
have to be from rivers Jesus I just want
a party you just want a cocktail party
with those little tidbits there you go
guys
your next question what is the I want to
talk more okay we didn't keep going I'm
more to say you have to say my sand no I
think that's it I think we have a great
exfoliant what is the best advice you
ever received
Oh God don't go to the problem for the
solution if someone is your problem
they're not your solution so like if
you're fighting with your significant
other don't try to no don't go to them
for the answer that's exactly right
they're your problem how can they
possibly be your solution divorce at
some point I think it's in the papers I
heard they're making an app a divorce
app it's why swipe right to divorce your
partner yeah there's a divorce at
present everyday a concept you still in
love or know a lawyer the lawyer that
Laura Dern's character in the marriage
story who she just won the Golden Globe
for that woman whose name escapes me at
the moment can we look up her name is is
making a divorce app I was just talking
to someone who is helping her
developments that seems yeah scary
honest it's pretty wild
I mean that was only a matter of time
you can't go to the problem for the
solution so you you know what we say in
program is you don't go to the problem
for the solution you take your problem
to your program and then your solution
to your relationship because a lot of
times your solution with someone is to
not talk to them at all are you most of
the time yeah most the time so you don't
go to someone go why are you acting that
way why are do you have the personality
disorder why is your neurology that they
can't fix it about themselves if they
could they would have especially in the
moment of the problem if you could start
writing them you already have all those
like chemicals going off in your head if
you have that conversation right away
that's crazy you should step back from
it and I have a hot take you might be
the problem you might have to go often
you're shit out you might have anger you
might have resentment you might be
respecting too much you might be too
judgmental you might have to just go off
fix that inside yourself become
powerless surrender and then shut your
mouth I would say nine times out of 10
both people are the problem yeah in most
arguments nine times out of 10 what is
this statistic they start if you're like
a housewife sometimes one of you ran
those TV shows like maybe you're the
problem I think everyone's a little bit
of both but to go to someone to be like
I don't like the way you're making me
feel fix it that never works that's the
definition of insanity that's doing the
same thing over and over again expecting
different results and that's spectin
someone else to solve your emotional
problem it is your job to figure out
what you need and then take it to them a
lot of times like I feel uncomfortable
fix it well how don't go to someone
without a solution so if you need
something from someone be very clear on
what it is don't expect them to be
psychic don't expect them to guess
though hey I need you to respond to my
text within a day can you do that or not
instead of going we don't talk enough
it's too vague you have to give people
very specific what if you have trouble
expressing your feelings you'd write
them down okay don't take it to the
person whose feelings are having trouble
expressing what you'll learn how
but what okay okay here's an option can
you write it down is that acceptable can
you write a note to a person if you can
say what you mean mean would you say
mean can verbalize better in a letter
than they can face-to-face a lot of
people yes but a lot of times writing
something down doesn't construe tone
right every email every message you send
is kind of a word shock test you know
when someone's like I would like to talk
to you period I'm like so you should
write it read it and rewrite it yeah if
you can say what you mean mean what you
say and don't say it mean if you don't
go hey I just need to talk to you about
something like if if you are sure that
the way you're writing something won't
get misconstrued tonally I think there's
a way to do it or just open the email
with hey I hope this doesn't come off
wrong I'm coming from a you know very
warm place here but I was wondering if
we can maybe talk about if we could
connect on the phone this is every day
instead of text or whatever you're
asking this is me but my default for all
texts or emails is to read them as if
they are excited I can happy positive
the default is to read everything with
an attitude great especially if there's
a period if I don't if I don't see an
exclamation I
zooom it's bitchy see but that's just
not good grammar that's yeah so that's
why that's what I will do so like I feel
like my d5 just over from my last office
job I fucking my default is just to read
everything as if it is coming from just
a nice lovely place yeah just assuming
the best in everyone yeah because if not
I think it's me it's my fault if it
comes off because I'm reading it to
myself yeah but it is your job as an
adult to be able to communicate clearly
and effectively and specifically and not
vaguely if you're have shitty vague
communication and the other person's not
doing what you want that's your fault
that's my truth um that's why animal
training has been so good for me because
I realize how vague I was always being
when I was asking for something and also
mean what you say say what you mean so a
lot of people like um I just I would
love it if you would like just maybe
like calm or like what you're saying and
how you're saying it aren't matching up
they have to match up you know right and
you can't just like no I'm fine it's
fine no like I'm okay and then expect
people to read your face and know that
that's not what you mean I'm fine and
otherwise available on Amazon a big fan
at the part so in the best advice I ever
got was you can't unring a bell can't
unscramble an egg
same thing can't uh neuter a dog yeah
like my Bell I mean I feel like we can
we can uh because that's just how it was
told to me that that was the best advice
and that's true it's just it's always
stuck with me at least just think cuz
once you say something you can't take it
back
though you can apologize and you can be
remorseful in that's true I think but
people are if you said it when in doubt
say nothing and I think it's taken me so
long to be able to be in a tense
situation with someone and just be like
you know what I hear you I need to
process this can I get back to you when
I have something cogent to say I just
I'm not prepared to respond right now I
see that all the time I'm not prepared
to respond right now I need to think
about it because in the emotion with all
the stress chemicals with the cortisol
with the adrenaline chances are you're
gonna respond to something in an
emotional way that's gonna you're gonna
regret in the future yeah almost always
can't unring about what about you you
have another one
yes feelings aren't facts oh great
advice
feelings aren't facts they're not let's
just set it right there you just you
have to know that about yourself when
you're emotional that doesn't mean
emotional about something if you're hurt
that doesn't mean someone meant to hurt
you
you know like I think that's why you've
seen me say that I don't wanna respond
to something for a couple days yeah
like if something is heated if
something's intense if something's with
a person you know that I have some kind
of like weirdness with and they asked me
for something I'm like you know I'll let
you know in three days that's why I
don't say yes to something for three
days because I'm gonna let all of the
feelings die down because I tried not to
make sort of permanent decisions based
on temporary feelings that's really I
mean that's feelings are temporary
anyway I think in all I think that you
can do that any any career any aspect
any relationship yeah I need a little
bit of time yeah and I think that if
they don't respect that that's on them
you deserve time to think about it and
that's why when someone asked me
something in person about doing
something or a question I go you know
what can you email me and then in the
privacy of my own home what I've eaten
something when I've hydrated myself when
I've taken a nap I can then respond from
a same place and not from a defensive
place or a place where I feel pressure
or guilt or obligation or any of that
shit very healthy you know feelings
aren't facts just because you're upset
doesn't mean someone's hurt you yeah
100% you know take responsibility for
your feelings it took me a long time to
kind of figure that out other good
advice get health insurance if you can't
get pet insurance like that's the kind
of advice in my twenties that I was
given that I did not take like floss
yeah floss was a great one I had floss I
was told one time to be a rock in a
river and that always stuck out to me
and I really really believe that it's
very helpful I like that what does that
mean exactly means that sometimes other
people's feelings and problems are not
yours so you let it just go around you
like water off a duck's back a rock and
a river I like that
don't take on other people's shit like
it's like it's not like there's a lot of
times where someone more like like
repeats I don't like things being
repeated to me a lot so when things are
repeated like I get really exhausting to
you that no because I this is a long
time ago I deal with this because I have
a manager that would do it all the time
and I would be like okay like this is
obviously I realized that that's not for
me that's how they are processing
however they are thinking and they are
feeling that is not about me just be a
rock in a river about it and so it's
just not about it so that's just how
they deal with something just like I
would deal with something a different
way that is so evolved in mature because
for me I repeat myself a lot I'm a
broken record about things especially
when I'm worried something isn't gonna
be done because as a kid I was not hurt
as a kid so I will ask something 50
times and it's not me
going you're dumb I assume you need me
to remind you it's my thing of going
like I'm just assuming that I'm not
important enough for you so this is like
an old defense mechanism and coping
mechanism to just keep saying the same
thing until it's done you know you know
we've been through that where I'm like
can you just tell me when this is done
so that I can stop asking cuz I feel
like I'm being patronizing insulting if
I keep asking yeah for sure and but no
one wants to be nagged yeah I know and I
also don't repeat myself so like when I
have something over no you don't like
repeating once I feel like it's I don't
know that problem from where to where
I'm having to justify away I feel the
way I think yeah and I thought it comes
from that you're very good at conserving
energy
you don't like spin your wheels around
something you say it and you're like no
I'm gonna give you the money for the now
that you've heard me and I'm rocking a
river you're rocking a river and you
gave me really good advice too they
don't let me should skip well what and
this is a really good advice you and I
think it's good for everyone because
even if you don't have like the
followers that like that like you have
on social media everybody reads other
people's comments and you one time told
me social media is the best of the best
and the worst of the worst and the real
world is somewhere in the middle and
that changed my entire outlook not only
the comments that I received but on the
comments and I read because I should
read like other people's comments like
just being out of interest and they were
so negative that oh my god like I know
I'm just now people can function like
this no that's not reality most healthy
people most people that follow us are
busy they have lives there do you have
jobs and they're not commenting they
look at your photo they're like a lot of
them don't like it just because they're
like I don't do that I don't need
arthritis and carpal tunnel I'm just
look at it move on you know most people
are not like that I think that everyone
on Twitter in Twitter in scrims
everybody's so negative everybody you
mean 5% of the population that you see
true and also the negative things stick
out in your brain work cuz it's your
brain protects you that way we've didn't
want you Benton and I have been talking
about this last couple days it once
we've been talking about negativity but
the ankles you know they said that's the
same thing with like if you don't wanna
go to the gym or something because like
it's hard yes your brain being it's hard
yeah your brain can protect you from
doing it even though you should which is
well cuz neuro chemicals are released in
things become more permanent when their
net you remember something five times
more strongly when it has a negative
feeling attached to it but that was good
advice and I thought we should bring it
up
what Dad you finally brought something
up what's the worst advice you ever got
though Oh
I don't like I hear this all the time
when people like do something every day
that scares you don't do don't don't do
that no need I already left my house is
enough when people say do something
every day that scares you I feel like
you're just bragging about having health
insurance what was the next one do you
have any advice I mean have more we're
going through a breakup no contact zero
no contact if you're going through a
breakup absolutely no contact not a text
not a peep
not a tweet don't even mumble to
yourself something you want to say to
the person don't when people make
contact with their exes it's it's like
you wouldn't eat out of the trash if you
threw some away you wouldn't if you
threw a yogurt away
speak for yourself two days later you
wouldn't go back out start scooping out
all the was left although I used to do
that when I used not want to eat
something I would just put it in the
trash and an hour later just like eating
cake out of the trash like I used to put
Windex on cake so that I wouldn't eat it
and you're doing well but then I like
midnight you're like I feel like there
were some areas that didn't have Windex
I think this is the thing you're like
I'm healthy I think I'll make it
there's no there when have you ever
heard people be like we broke up and
then we met a month later to get closure
and like we figured it out right unless
you have kids let it go great point
never works out no number of awkward
coffee closure dates are gonna fix your
relationship and if it's gonna work out
it'll work out down the road on its own
trying it out do nothing you're picking
at a scab and it's gross and it's
annoying I got it's the worst to have to
hear about it when your friends are
doing it well no we're just gonna like
meet for a coffee and just like talk
about what happened penis not such a
good metaphor for that oh is it
that's very satisfying to do as well you
know what I mean yes as much as you want
to do it you just can't you know reopen
the wound are you liking oh god it's so
gross but it's a you know it's it's
really hard to see when you're not in it
when you're like no I really need to
talk to this person again my thing is if
you have something to say to the person
write it in an email send it to one of
your friends and if you can't send it to
one of your friends which most people
can't because it'd be too embarrassing
don't send to anyone
it goes back to fillings are not facts
they're not fillings are not facts but I
love the way you pronounce feelings feel
tellings I like what you're doing with
your hair - you're growing my headband
so yeah Benton has grown his hair really
long I'm growing taller I'm growing
stronger every door okay anymore because
we have Fred Armisen here and he's one
of the greats do you have any um
self-work boosting tips self-worth what
I could work but self-worth boosting
tips Oh God
I mean people ask me this a lot I don't
think people understand that if you want
to have self-worth you have to do things
that make you worth the yeah things like
people are like how do I get self-esteem
you have to do with Ste mobile actions
people think just like looking at
inspirational quotes and reading fortune
cookies is all of a sudden gonna make
them have high self esteem you have to
do things you're actually proud of you
have to go be of service yeah and it's
not even that difficult like for me like
being honest really good I know that
people know that I'm not lying and that
makes my life so much but just a little
lies you know when you're like sorry I
can't make it tonight like sweet little
lies my flight like I did this a little
bit over the holiday where I pretended I
was traveling when I stay at home just
cuz I didn't want to deal with people so
I just was like my flights late but I
didn't go anywhere yeah well that's
different I guess I know but there's
little lies that chip away at your
self-esteem because you start going like
I'm not an honest person you know I
think to be to have self-esteem you have
to do esteem Abul actions another one
that really helps me is not gossiping
it's oh yeah it's really hard but gossip
I think just makes you feel dirty to say
it just makes you feel ashamed
afterwards it makes you feel small yeah
it makes you yeah and also ties your
self-worth to another person and the bad
things that they're going through to
meaning to degrade them to you know
uplift yourself I feel I did thirty days
no gossip once just to see if I could do
it to sort of change that habit and the
neurology in my brain it was really
challenging it's wild how much we all
gossip about people and how much we need
to do that yeah it's one of how much we
like it to know industry yeah it's just
so I try to not gossip or say anything
negative about anyone I also get a cut
off people that don't treat you well and
degrade you because I think we take cues
from other people of how to believe you
know in ourselves or not like friends
who are just I don't I don't play the
shit I don't place shit when women are
like hey bitch hey hooker like I don't
play that shit don't talk to me
like that I'll let people talk to me
like that well you mean you teach people
how to treat you yeah I just and when
people are late that's a big one if
you're in friendships of people that are
late that sends a signal that you're not
worth their time and then you start your
self-worth starts to lower unless you
say something instead of boundary like
you can't be late with me anymore you
have to do that I think your self-esteem
gets higher when you protect yourself
and don't let people disrespect to you
true I think doing some that you're
really passionate about also raises your
esteem because that's good makes you
feel like you're doing something with
your life yeah like a hobby look in
12-step programs the one of the biggest
parts of it is being of service as dorky
as that sounds
taking the focus off yourself and
helping another person helps you build
your self-esteem being of service and
doing things without strings and like I
used to in the my old house there was a
guy that lived a couple houses down
who's this older man who had this long
driveway and he couldn't it took him a
long time to get his cans out for
garbage day and I like started getting
up and like on Thursdays and taking his
garbage to the front and it made me feel
so good about myself well of course it
did yeah but I think we forget that
we're we're so we're such a narcissist
now we're always like how could my
self-esteem be better how can you guys
help me yeah you have to do something
actively yes to build your self-esteem
self-esteem it's not given to you by
anyone else it is built by your actions
and behavior it's because we live in a
world where that's like you know my
feelings are valid I'm valid this is
valid and then you end up just thinking
about yourself
yeah and how to validate yourself yeah
all the time
yeah that's it's so true your last
question we're still running out of sand
but what are we gonna do about the sand
I mean look that is a really complicated
question and there's a lot more to say
with that and we have Gary Gulman coming
up on a future episode and I feel like
we're gonna dig in to a lot of that but
you if to have self-esteem you have to
do esteem Abal actions
everyone's asked me about the skin yeah
that's the next one what is your
skincare routine please please tell us I
feel like we just need to get this out
of the way because everyone wants to ask
about my skin everyone it's so funny
because my comments are either you're
too shiny or I love your skin how do I
get it so I can't tell if people think
my skin is good or bad and the office
somewhere in the middle as a wise
nutcase once said I also think people
think I'm like 64 so I can't tell the
people thinking I just have nobody
really stop making things that's not
good for your self-esteem you're right
don't make up your own gossip guys
that's a good one shit about yourself
okay let's just go down this get a pen
get a piece of paper if you're a guy
listening this applies to you to guys or
no to take care of their skin yes and
also guys try things out before we even
start because what we say works may not
work for you so try stuff out on but
guys pulled me aside all the time you
know like hey what do you do to your
skin like they're so ashamed to ask
about it and you're like estrogen is our
men's skin and women's skin different
yes men have this is and I mean there's
only physically yeah and have thicker
skin they do they have thicker skin and
so like products that are really harsh
on women maybe like perfect for them
dirt you can just your skin's bigger I
see so you have to think about there's
something hair follicles on the guy's
skin how interesting so exfoliating
astringent men skin can just tolerate a
little more retinol acids
oh okay so here's my full routine I'm
just gonna tell you you guys this might
be boring but all of you are asking look
at me doing the exact thing we're making
fun of guys everyone's asking me on the
edge of your seat I know you're dying to
know most people are like we have no
interest in this okay first thing I do
is I wash my face I know this sounds
obvious but I use a exfoliating mitt
just get it on Amazon it's a it's a
ridiculous glove that you just scrub
everything off with and then I normally
use that drunk elephant stuff that you
got oh the cleanser jelly the jelly or
the Tata Harper pump really good ones
yes very good one they sent a bunch of
stuff for the guests and I got hooked on
it I also use grapeseed oil you know I
use this I use a vat of grapeseed oil
all over my body and face constantly yes
if she sees grapeseed oil somewhere you
can test she'll just put it on that's
why I look like an orca so I do that not
to be everyone's like what do I wash my
face with just keep it simple used of
soap for all I care I don't do not do
not use def so that is insanity do not
look today
Oh it'll strip your face it just that is
for your body soap is body washes buff
has a face wash yeah read the
ingredients on everything guys
okay well what ingredients should you
not get uh that is personal but I would
say would stay away for anything with
like I say with anything that has
ingredient that I can't go --gel and
find out exactly what it okay I like
that that's a very good rule don't put
anything on your face or in your body
that you can't pronounce I like that
that's a good rule or can't Google a lot
of things so I go for what I can't
google and find information okay the
next thing I do is I do a derma roller
you guys have lots of questions about
this it's a little prickly medieval
torture device that has little metal
pricks on it it makes microscopic holes
in your skin so that your product
actually absorbs because most of our
product doesn't absorb because of all
the dense dead skin cells on top so this
is a way to actually get your expensive
product that you spend all your money on
into actual skin like I do it every
other day if you're just starting you
should not do it every other day
it helps beard growth too is it for this
thing who's they doctors and
dermatologists the derma roller are also
doubles as a sex device if you're into
that kind of thing I would replace your
derma roller every month yeah I read the
package will tell you in the package
yeah depending on how much it's don't
ask me where to find it just go find it
derma roller look at him and stop asking
me and then I do the skin eternal serum
this is literally twenty five dollars at
Whole Foods I get it on Amazon I'm
talking about it now because I just
bought like ten of them so that you guys
don't buy them and there's no left for
me it is s thirsty dmae and alpha lipoic
acid it is a combination that dr.
Perricone talked about in his book
called the wrinkle cure which I read
twelve years ago when I was with Busy
Philipps
in Scotland making that movie it changed
my life started using that shit and
that's when people first started
complimenting my skin go buy it I don't
buy the dr. Perricone brand unless he
wants to advertise on our show but
that's it buy it stop asking me about it
skin
eternal serum the brand is source
Naturals thank you other things people
don't know that I do that I think make a
difference
one silk pillowcase guide you that to
see I didn't know you did that yeah look
at us all may do that I do it a silk
pillowcase so what people do is they put
their product on and then they go lay
down on the bed and then their cotton
pillowcase sucks up all their product so
you're spending eight hours sleeping at
night with none of your product on it's
good to have beards because you don't
have that weird like oh that's a great
gift to buy your boyfriend or husband or
to buy yourself silk pillowcase in
colors like navy black oh they do I
haven't seen that um I haven't I haven't
bought in a while I do white and they're
all Turkish oh dude the amount of
product I put in my face before bed my
pillowcases are disgusting
I also this is gonna sound insane but it
works I put my product on an hour before
bed because a lot of people put the
product on and then they just lie down
and it gets rubbed off by their pillow
right I also sleep straight up like a
vampire and I put my back to you but
I've been in my whole life really I
never have I only sleep in my side I'm
taking a nap all the treats excuse me
wait that's so I've never heard that
before you sleep on your side for like
quick quick bouts of sleep
yeah just cuz like whatever I've had
guys say to me like it is so creepy how
you just sleep like you're in a coffin
and I don't move the entire night I
weren't I'm asking everything but I put
on noise-cancelling headphones so that
my head doesn't move from side to side
and the product gets smeared off I'm
straight up and my product stays on all
night I wake up still greasiest but yes
and also if you're not this extreme by
the time you an hour into your products
they're probably desorbs though I know
but then they stay on all night like my
really goopy yeah yeah cuz I always put
oil on right before bed and everyone's
like but I can't use oil I'm gonna break
out opposite when you use oil it
actually stops your oil glands from
producing oil when you dry your skin out
then they have to compensate and produce
more oil and that's when you break out I
just to break out all the time because I
would dry my skin out with a brace of
shit and oils and retinas and alcohol
and sea breeze sea breeze was nice and
your skin can't produce water but it can
produce oil so that's why you make so
much of it oh I'm a big fan of
hyaluronic acid because it will bond
moisture from the air to yours I like
Hydra Lana casa - it's just the price
ranges are so varied interesting that no
line what's the best brand for that
I mean I like the dr. Danish gross one
oh yeah I like that one a lot I don't
like about like $60 it's like it's 60 or
100 some like that very different prices
that's a wild amount of money but I also
like the ordinary makes a great one
ordinary oh I like that brand you're
right
you right you right because literally
you can find a $5 one on Amazon and then
like a $300 one and then I panic and use
a physical exfoliator but that glove I
have a chemical till here is a duck
genus peel pads
dr. Dennis dr. Danish gross okay the
full thing you know dr. Dennis you know
dr. Dennis gross the bat I did I must
have skipped it the peel pads I used the
blue ones which are the the more
hydrating ones and I run into my beard
and everything I run that I use all and
they clean we didn't I gotten a full
fight about this yesterday I was like
tomorrow can you explain how to wash
your beard on the show and he's like
yeah I just watched it like my face I'm
like you have to be that that's not
helpful how do you actually wash your
beard what my face no no literally in an
uber like going apeshit being like can
you please explain how to wash your
beard in a way that people will
understand visually what do you think
your verse or is now Sierra whatever I
put on my face whatever I'm washing with
I massage into my beer whatever it is
that mean show it to us you're looking
on camera it's like I just massage it
into my beer oh you do think you kind of
finger it you kind of like crystals
water I mean I'm doing that for you but
in real life I would just be doing this
but don't you have to get down there cuz
I mean I I've ever dated with a beard
gets dry under the beer most guys wash
their face with like body wash and it's
gonna dry your face out Oh
what face wash you use I used the drunk
elephant one or I use if I have I
thought I could have acne or something
coming on I'll use a ceramic slip by
Sunday rally what do you do if there's
little red dots on your hairs that's
your bet you're the hair fall clothes
it's getting in findeth it's so dry
because you're not putting any product
on a lot of people think that's as it
and then they dry it out I'd be but
normally it's not yeah and sometimes
it's ingrown hairs yes sometimes ingrown
hairs which if you're but I mean
whatever products you're putting on your
beard mhm
are seeping down to your skin there look
I have by that they are they're just
like it's like anything you ever had
funny put a hair oil on your hair and
they run it through here they don't put
it right at your root yeah
travel to your wrist oh okay so you're
putting beard oil or cream on your beard
I put all my moistures everything in my
beer but I do a lot of guys asked about
I do use a beard oil I use the premium
classic beard oil from The Art of
Shaving oh yeah it's like the big one
lightly vanilla scented which I really
like because most immersed and I tend to
play cigarettes my producer just wrote
on the screen guys
dot dot dot I will talk about beards for
another 40 minutes and I'm looking at
both my producers who both have giant
beards who are probably fucking dry you
guys probably need to hear this
oh yeah Gary oh shit okay I got to stop
talking about beards this is crazy
literal ones metaphorical ones all of
them our guest today is one of my
favorite people in the planet
I was very nervous to ask him to do this
and I actually kind of tried to talk him
out of it the night before Fred armed is
that I was like do I do the podcast and
he said yes right away and then the de
vars like are you sure you know this is
like a podcast it's just like are you
sure that like I got so insecure about
asking him because I'm such a big fan
and I actually really like this
conversation because he doesn't like try
super hard to do bits no he's very
soothing as well he's very like genuine
and he says what he means it means what
he says he doesn't say it mean it does
not say it mean he's just one of the
kindest most gentle is that a gross word
to say about someone it's weird but he
felt he's very I feel very safe with him
yeah he's very interesting too because
he he only cannot fall ya'll talks about
things that he like he's like passion
about like if he didn't know something
you were talking about he was talking
about whenever he knew something he
that's why I was interesting cause he
was talking up really passionately about
things he knew about yeah I I worry I
was being a little anxious I'm a fan and
I even got me worked on it a little bit
of a sycophant know I'm such a big fan
and when people come in that I'm a big
fan of I don't want to be like so corny
and annoying and like just like
compliment him the whole time so it was
like I feel like I hope I wasn't too no
I think you were fine I think he would I
think you were fine
I think you were fine about it that's
what I strive for in this podcast I'm
just fine I mean you want to be a little
bit of a fan you want to be like and you
I think it was really uh yeah I think
was a good interview if I was I kind of
blacked out a couple times and I had
like a nanobot it's a great interview I
was spinning after the any brows that
was awful
I didn't ask interesting questions that
made no sense and then I listened back
to it I was like oh wow I would wanted
to hear everyone in the room loved it
it's great interview you should rate
comment subscribe on it's wonderful it's
Fred Armisen isn't it
if you it's more of a psychological
thing um what do you accept what do you
think I don't know you're doing it I
know but I think it's more because it
makes me it's like a Pavlovian thing
where I feel like focus more I suppose
also if people when people watch it
they're like oh this was meant for audio
as opposed to like we're on a show this
is more like this is the focus is the
sound of it people and on people also
know they're like oh that's a podcast
they're not acting yeah yeah they're not
dressed for it's it's kind of a costume
it is kind of it's a prompt it's uh it's
not necessary shy drink water during
this isuh you can let's do some ASMR but
opening the door there you go turning
the doorknob videos I had to for
something on Seth Meyers
um we had to do like a parody of it and
I wasn't familiar with it oh wow so um
so I had to like watch and listen it was
it's amazing you liked it as a musician
um not that much it's almost it's too
much so I said it's fine I love that it
exists but it is um it's more funny to
me than I need I mean I'm just happy
about it but I it's it's just I'm almost
like too sensitive to it me too it gives
me um like it's like nails on a
chalkboard to me yeah you know some
people just have that audio response but
for a lot of people it feels like
orgasmic and soothing to them yeah I
guess not this guy now
here no this is so funny because I feel
like we're better friends than we are is
that okay yeah I like that feeling and I
I sometimes trust it
sometimes I'm fine with hey it seems
like we know each other it seems like
we're friends and that to me is good
enough like when I last time I saw you I
just felt like very familiar with you
you know and even if it's because I've
seen you on things or because you know
it could be because also because of your
stand-up um sometimes when I feel like
oh I identify with something or if I
like it I'm like okay we're in the same
like or in the same sort of region and
there's also I think that when you make
someone laugh it's such an intimate
thing yeah like you've made me laugh for
so long so I feel like when I see you I
actually got shy when I was in Vancouver
that we last saw each other by the way I
think it's very glamorous to not
remember cities is the best thing it's
like such a like it was London I think
we did that show in Belfast I think we
travel so much that we don't know the
idea of pretending you don't remember a
place you hung out so that you could
brag about all the place I'm like oh
well you bought something like I got
this I think in Prague was it yeah it
was a Copenhagen or was it Belgium oh my
god it's that's so but like that's I
have a theory about jetlag that it's
just how people can brag that they've
been travelling absolutely right I don't
even totally believe in jetlag I know I
cuz I don't fight it I'm always like I'm
tired yeah but um I think people do that
also with the list of things they have
to do for work so so Idol and and I do
fitting still awake you know hadn't
slept in like 20 hours had to go you
know how to do this impress I'm just
like I can't do this much press but that
guy is the kind of bragging of like I am
so busy and my flight was this long
people love being busy they love
complaining about how busy they are her
tired they're the new thing I'm finding
is almost like a Munchausen's people
like love being sick they're like I've
been said because I just was on a plane
and then I was sick and then I
bronchitis not like I had to take a
z-pack and I'm like do you love meeting
sick because these talk about it or
whatever we us every but when people
talk with such warmth like this real on
one I want to talk about this and and so
my allergies it's like there's a
medication I need it and so I'll and and
everyone was sick it's a fluid the whole
tour had it yeah the whole crew had yeah
and I got it I got some attention and I
also when people are bragging about how
sick their I'm like go home go home
you're telling me how sick you are
you're getting ever is the most selfish
thing no I don't want I just I want to
stay and work through no I Melissa I
should just be here like don't touch me
just that's what you have I'm just
drinking this tea it's like that tea
that's there though hmm in the sea I did
the sea they tell you the whole routine
I did the vitamins I did the oregano I
did the Wellness formula like everything
but sleep and take care of yourself yeah
you're doing and you're not the first
person to get sick
they act like it's like usually I'm not
a person who becomes sick but I am just
I just don't get it sag but also I love
when people go out in public and you're
like hey what's up like I don't touch me
yeah it's like thing don't be here oh ho
oh so you're not that sick what do you
have a sore throat oh that's so funny oh
wait and now uh-oh Vancouver is where
yes or or Belgravia wherever we're ever
was that's where yeah that's I think
that's where it was who's the comedy
festival I was so nervous to meet you
actually I don't get nervous meeting
people but come on I don't I really
don't there's like a couple people that
I would geek out on in you I'm gonna be
honest I'm I was I'm such a fan I was so
afraid like what if he's not like I
don't know I was just like I don't want
to meet him because if it's like I just
don't want it to like ruin how much I
love because I've had a lot of people
disappoint and you were so nice and so
warm instantly and it was like a hug
around my heart well okay the way I see
it and this is it's gonna sound like
false humility
but I see you as like very established
and like in the real thing like you're
like she's like actually does like legit
real touring and and your shows and
everything so I just feel a little bit
like I was like she knows who I what it
sounds I send Garth and Kat to everyone
around the holidays for like like the
whole month I have a chain going like
it's a it's like a thing me and my
friends like will do it to each other
like a very big part of its really nice
well at least that's funny those
perceptions so wild yeah and your
standard for drummers is I I love it so
much and I'm so fascinated by the things
that you observe like you pick up on
things that I'm just like that's a level
of observation that I just will never
understand just wouldn't you pick up on
I don't want to botch your joke but
about when people will elongate the last
word I think it was the hair yes we
don't do any advertise yeah
that's something that really happened I
know how do you like my brain I just
would shut off when people start I'm
just like you know but you're the I
think your observations are it's also
like the way people are and it's visual
and art you know the sound of it but um
I just try to focus on sound stuff is
all that so that so it just it's in line
with the rest of the specials so it's
observations about people it's like the
sounds people make and yeah question and
it's just sort of like lingers for a
moment I what do you think that is like
I'm so obsessed with our epigenetics and
our ancestors and how it primed us to be
a certain way do you think it's because
your grandfather was a spy picking up on
things and observing well that's kind of
you to say that I'm good at it I you
know I'm not walking in your yeah this
is hard because I wouldn't Grohl was in
here remember I tried to tell him like
Foo Fighters is one of the few bands
that's really really big and also still
cool yeah and he was like we're not cool
we're a dad band we're not like
really talented people I'm realizing you
can't give compliments like Bill burr
was in here the other day and I was just
like don't say he's funny I know that's
like his like third rail trigger oh is
it really
yeah he doesn't he doesn't do well was
saying like you're one of the best
comics working right now he's like it I
think that truly great people don't ever
see themselves that way yeah I think
you're right about that you know so I'll
stop making you cum no no no I'm it's
very nice oh that I want to but I'd also
know what you think I'm like no because
yeah when when yeah it's a tricky thing
it is a tricky thing but you are so
gifted at being able to like hear things
a lot of people might not pick up on
well I think that comes from the fact
that my parents are English isn't their
first language and we moved around a lot
so my mom has Venezuelan so we spoke
Spanish a lot so I think it's sort of
just hearing different languages than it
that gets you into that and then um
about the Foo Fighters I agree with you
like they put out like sort of
experimental records and how many bands
are that big and cool like yeah it was
amazing to watch Coldplay be everyone's
favorite band
yeah and that it was a full Coldplay
like they became I know it's everyone's
problem people are weird with stuff like
that when something gets too mainstream
I think they for some reason decide that
like well then I don't like it but I
feel like you two Green Day Foo Fighters
have managed to stake we have despite
how big they are yeah um definitely I
mean there's a bunch
um but Foo Fighters yeah they seem to
love music to us yes like they seem to
want to play and I feel like Dave is
always sort of like into talking about
music I just yeah I think what do you
listen to like new stuff um I'm so
fascinated what like music aficionados
choose to listen to especially new music
there's an artist named Kate Teague that
I really like and there's another Kate
Kate Lebon mm-hm
but she's been out for a like a while so
it's not that new but she's she's great
yeah and this is band called real estate
who I love oh yeah that sounds cool
really good and I'm so bad at music I'm
still listening to the
dancing soundtrack that's like I do you
I have a thing with music where I think
right now I'm going back to like not
oldies but like albums that I listen to
when things work like easy and good like
musics like comfort food like new music
sometimes I'm like can't do it I don't
think there's such a thing as being bad
at listening to music that's that's just
where your taste lies and that's that's
valid and Benton remember when we
decorated the Christmas tree with no
music it was terrifying I was just like
I can't listen to music right now like
when I listen to music it's like a it's
a fully immersive thing like I have to
really oh I'm the same
I can't multi-tap like background music
I don't like can't do it no I don't like
like let's talk about music is know
which one of the other I can't that's
that's one or the other I can't do that
I can't just have music on in the house
all the time
no it's it's in it's in my car when I'm
alone yes and on planes don't you pick
music to put you in a certain mood yes
that's what I do also I'm like I'm
feeling a like I need a pickup today I'm
gonna listen to Flashdance yes or if I
want to disappear into something I'll
just appear into something dreamy I'm
gonna go this direction I think I'm just
so sensitive and impressionable in a way
that the mood of a song can change my
mood and I know how sensitive I am to it
yeah like turn it off I don't wanna go
there yeah I'm not gonna be emo today
yes you know or I could push you further
into a mood that you're in just pushes
you deeper yeah can you work while you
listen to music like oh no no no just
silence separate separate yeah that's
wild yeah
when I was at SNL I never listen to
music and I didn't have any decorations
in my office either really I don't like
I don't like hey this is my home and I'm
like yeah hold cool that's really smart
because I think the amount that we
distract ourselves in the amount we like
pollute our periphery yeah and it's sort
of it's also um it's like also just
trying to take over the space I'm like
what the yeah does that mean you know
that I'm gonna have all my stuff I like
things really clinical and boring yeah
and it makes you work I don't like to
get too comfortable
I don't like comfortable chairs I like
to keep it kind of holds agree I don't
like to get cozy
at work no that's not it's not the job
it's like Works job isn't to be a cozy
place can I admit something embarrassing
to you yeah I never like I know I know
yours talked about SNL all the time but
I was just thinking about you coming in
today and I was like what's my
experience with SNL besides just like
being a fan like my dad and i's whole
relationship revolved around that
landshark sketch oh yeah like we had a
really tricky relationship but we'd
always crack each other up with like
landshark like that's how we would knock
on the door that's how we would like cut
tension yeah with like SNL skits growing
up that would always like break up a
fight you know and so I have a very like
deep connection to it but I remember
when I first I think I had was doing
something so I wasn't actually properly
able to either like audition or submit a
packet but I remember writing a sketch
for a packet that I never was able to
submit because of something else and I
wrote a sketch so stupid but I thought
it was so funny it was about you know
how guys call each other nicknames like
champ and chief emboss or whatever and
these guys like sitting around watching
football like yeah what up champ like
come on whatever buddy and then one of
them goes to order pizza and the pizza
guy's like so what's the name of the
address and the guy realizes he doesn't
know his friend's name because he's been
calling him nicknames for so long like I
just love the idea of like guys not
actually knowing mrs. no I just like
wrote I just I was like putting a packet
together and I thought it'd be funny to
tell my embarrassing like oh yeah that's
not dumb it's you know it's just like a
silly thing that I just was cranking
myself up with like the things that you
think we're funny like eight years ago
yeah it's good because also it's simple
like it doesn't go and did the leg it
says I like this that's my favorite day
one of my favorite parts of Portlandia
specifically how simple the premise is
like you go you go like yeah that's a
sketch yeah basically we try to keep it
that way and when it started getting
complicated
it was our director who's kind of like
this is let's simplify it yeah
were there any sketches that you kind of
like gave up on or wish you had done
that you hadn't done no the ones that we
cut I'm glad that we cut really oh yeah
some stuff we just was just too
complicated and
and when something doesn't work it just
doesn't work so um there's a lot we cut
you know there anywhere you're like I
know this this is still funny to me like
I know it like there's a couple jokes I
feel like I'm finally at the place where
I'm like this is like hit 70% of the
time I like it yeah yeah so I'm just
keeping it in like I'm kind of at that
point now do you mean in sketches in
stand-up Oh in stand-up I'm like this
kind of hits and it usually will hit
based on how into it I am that night but
or in certain cities it won't hit but
I'm like you know what I like it this
one's for me I don't know how you do it
what do you mean you're on stage it's
just you and a microphone and you're
like a boxer or something you're just
like there's no shaky part of it you
just like on stage and it's just it's
like a battle it's fantastic you really
from everyone loves it all the way
through from the show that I saw and you
just there are no it never does this it
was just well it's so funny because yet
we did shows the same night I did what I
think it aid and you did tear something
and it was so interesting because I was
watching your show and all like oh hell
like take a second to go behind the drum
set there and then whole there's so much
tension in between when you kill that I
feel like the jokes hit even harder oh
right in a way and then you've got your
set like it's so it's so interesting
that we are admiring the complete
opposite things about each other yeah
that's really funny that was like he's
got all this patience because he knows
the joke is gonna hit so he can take as
much time as he needs to you know well
whenever I see John Bryan at Largo mm-hm
he's got all these instruments and stuff
it's kind of um endearing when he
doesn't know which instrument to go to
interesting and I like the sort of like
he's sort of walking around almost like
a scientist or something so that makes
me trust that it's gonna be oh that's
interesting it's really about letting
the audience know that you're in control
yeah I think with stand-up like when
it's just you in a microphone there is
like you have to be a trained yes and I
think I'm especially like I mean it
might even come from insecurity it might
not be particularly like
but I think now that like with phones
and with heckling cuz heckling I think
has gotten worse with being on podcast
and and people thinking they know you
really well so it's also my way of
making sure no one has a second to yell
something out because they will for me
they they always well and does that
throw you off
it doesn't throw me off it's just like I
don't I think you saw me right before I
was like taping something so I was
Charlie yeah yeah I was trying to like
get the timing down I was trying to get
the rhythm I like I was changing the
order of things like I just didn't have
time to like deal with someone's like
divorce in the audience you don't I mean
like I just don't want to deal with
someone's like bachelorette party or
whatever it was I mean Benton's seen it
like people will try to you know come on
stage they will throw things on set like
people will ask me really intimate
questions while I'm on stage and I just
I also never want to be a dick who's
like shutting someone down yeah that can
be that can come off as angry sometimes
in a way that's like no matter how right
you think you are yeah and it's also a
time where it can feel mean real fast
like I remember when I was coming up and
a girl would yell in the audience the
comic would just be like would someone
put a dick in her mouth and everyone
allow you move on but now it's like I do
get a lot of women and if someone's like
drunk and just like wants to be my
friend there's no way I can make it stop
without coming off like a dick yeah you
get positive heckling that's right
that's right
that I want to be helpful yeah and there
or those try to yell out punch line so
it's just something where I think you
just have to let them know right away
like these are the rules
uh-huh it's when they're drunk usually
drunk is where that happens where that's
right you can feel it that's right and I
think it's it gets really dicey and I've
gotten in situations before where it
goes sour and it's just a bummer and
it's just like you know so I think for
me I just try to go so fast that there's
no room for any of that I try to let it
get boring it's fascinating so if
someone's talking and I just let it
become a boring boring moment so that it
they almost so far you know they just
move on themselves cuz it's just this is
going knowing see that is so that is the
bravest most gangster shit I don't know
I have ever heard anyone say
it's just it's their idea they're like
Fred can you keep going yeah like you
make it their idea okay just sit with
this moment if it's so important to you
people around them who are sort of like
this has become mrs. slowing everything
down and then you let people just know
that's the most alpha shit you can do is
just let people know like yeah I'm the
talented one you miss it you miss me
talking know you it's a it's a that's
kind of the feel yeah yeah like let this
play out oh yeah if you're better than
me let's listen to you yeah and it
usually dies down pretty quick although
I gotta say people have been really nice
in in my touring I know I bet I mean I
think you have we probably have people
with manners
I think cuz I do a couple things I've
got like the roasts
I think cuz I did the roasts in the
beginning and it brings out this like
yes I get like sometimes like truculent
people who think it's funny to yell
insults at me
whoa so I get a lot of and I'm walking
through an airport people are like hey
bitch and I'm like okay it's like 2:30
why not you know
how do you handle that in the moment I
just laugh mm-hmm yeah thank you
yeah I just keep going I always wear
noise-cancelling headphones in the
airport or the headphones and pretend
I'm on the phone oh and I just like
things but I think that maybe I get a
little bit of that so I think I get
insecure when I'm performing and feel
like I have to just like flow through it
because if someone yells something mean
at me everyone else will get like
protective oh yeah yes and they gang up
on how to control it's a whole thing
yeah you know and I think I have a
little bit of residual anxiety about one
show that I did in Napa actually Napa is
a pretty conservative area and I think
this was maybe like I don't know what I
was talking about Obama like it wasn't
even a bomb it wasn't even a political
joke but I said something and someone
just yelled out you know Hillary's a
cunt mm-hmm just yelled it and then I
was just like because I try to not that
sounds like drunken behavior though
correct and then I saw some movement on
the right and then shuffled over and
then
people started physically fighting and I
ran offstage and I got so freaked I've
never I don't think I've ever recovered
from it because that's when you really
realize like oh these are a bunch of
drunk people yeah it only takes one
crazy person and then it just becomes
Lord of the Flies yeah you think of it
in a saloon or a bar and it's like in
Napa in Napa
there still it was like my vacation
weekend but I think that's when you
realize like oh my gosh it's actually
weird that there aren't more fights like
this like we get AB yeah you know yeah
and Jim Jefferies the chair Rhys I mean
he had someone he's had people run on
stage multiple times really yeah he had
someone punch him in the face
on stage why oh it's wild will you pull
this up oh this will blow your mind what
fears he had made a joke I think it was
about suicide or something but and
someone went onstage and fought him I
think it might have been in Australia or
maybe Germany oh I know I know Marc
Maron had one of those yeah yeah god
that's can you imagine going to a comedy
show and being like I'm ready to go up
on stage I'm saying as an audience
member yeah I'm gonna fight that
comedian I think it just makes you
realize like there are you know it only
takes one person the Comedy Store
Manchester so this is in this is so wild
haha yeah I mean crazy oh my god he's
continually punching him you know it's
stuff like this oh my god this is my
nightmare is that while I think that
when you do material that could you know
for lack of better word this word is
overused now but like upset people
trigger people like I think he was
talking about something that sets
somebody off pleasure but the answer is
if you're that audience member to just
walk out that you have to just leave
alright this is you know not where I
wanted to be today yeah although it
would be pretty great to have a show
where it's like a full-on like mosh pit
like the whole theater is just like
everyone that might be kind of like yeah
pretty cool but I think um and maybe
maybe coming up with a comedy store or
something that you've just seen so much
violence with audience members that I
think I feel the need to just like
machine-gun through it yeah you do it
but it's fun but you see it's still
friendly though you're very like I'm
gonna say this
now I'm gonna say this and I'm gonna say
this oh it was great
I just love watching you because it
feels like you're having so much fun I
love it
you're having so much fun I love it I
can't wait to do more so you're touring
again and are you gonna do another
special yeah that's the hope uh I'm
doing stuff that's more based on the
guitar uh-huh and I just love it I just
did a tour of Australia I loved it I
love Australia and the shows were great
have you I'm sure you've been there I
haven't been there ever I was supposed
to do shows there night to cancel for
something really weird I've never been
oh you gotta go the best crowds best
crowds the the whole country is just
beautiful it's huge yeah you went to
Sydney and Melbourne Brisbane and Perth
and then Auckland New Zealand
what crowds in the world that you've
been to have been the weirdest oh that's
a really good question
mine was Belgium well what what was the
tour like was it like Belgium I was
doing Scandinavia and I went to Belgium
and it was in like a week they don't
have a lot of comedy venues it was like
an old bank where the sound just kind of
dissipated like it didn't bounce off
anything I currently reverberate so I
just you know those venues where you
kind of feel like you're bombing cuz you
can't hear yourself yeah there was no
like kickback like I was just like
bombing into the ether like in a bank in
Belgium so weird and and after every
joke they would clap they didn't really
laugh it was more of a clap and to be a
cultural thing I went up afterwards I
was like what was that that was crazy
why were they clapping that was so
patronizing they're like oh they were
trying to be polite oh and I was like
well that's there's no room for that
here that's not what we're doing I mean
god I'd love to do a show in Belgium
that's crazy
it was pretty wild but I just and then
when I was in a Scandinavia I think that
the hour I was doing at the time was
very much about like being in
relationships where you were
disrespected and a lot of it didn't hit
because they were like we don't
disrespect women over there's too much
equality I was doing so bit about
like when a guy hangs up on you and
you're fighting and everyone was like
what guys no one related I can't like
that that might you should have given
them a mic as well I don't do that when
I went to Norway I was doing some joke
about strip clubs and some lady finally
just yelled out like we don't have those
here okay thank you and I was like why
not what's wrong with you bunch of
pussies they were like we respect women
over here we don't do that which country
when I was Norway in Bergen Bergen
doesn't have strip clubs Wow hey I know
I like your tour that's like half my act
I've never done that I mean I've never
toured in Europe oh you would I mean I'm
dying to - I would love to I would love
to you Australia and then what's next
um do you mean like anything like a tour
together uh yeah I haven't booked it yet
but April cuz shooting was a Spooky's in
in Santiago only starting at all
February yeah every part to be there for
like three months or something every
project you do is like you never fail at
anything that's really nice thank you
Oh Shalom do you buy stuff online
do you sell stuff online to me cuz all I
do is buy stuff online from people that
sell things you're probably still
recovering from that crazy holiday
shopping season well I have a way to
make you help you sorry you have a way
to help you make 2020 a lot less crazy
and a lot more successful station ship
station makes managing and shipping out
orders ah breathing important orders
from any sales channel ship with any
carrier using our deeply discounted
rates automate just about any shipping
task with ship station you'll spend less
time on shipping and more time growing
your business is no wonder ship station
has more five-star reviews than any
other shipping software I'm not
surprised no matter where you're selling
Amazon Etsy your own website oh should
we use this when we do our um we'll have
stuff to sell soon right pop sockets the
things that stick to your phone if we
finally figured that out what they are
Asian works at all the major carriers
UPS FedEx UPS you best
United States Postal Service PS I didn't
know there was a USPS and EU PS wow
that's like a nightmare the Postal
Service you can compare and choose best
shipping solution for you and your
customer it's a number one choice of
online sellers you'll ship more in less
time with the best rates available get
this year off to a great start at ship
station comm use my offer code Whitney
not Congrats Whitney to get a 60 day
free trial that's two months free no
hassle stress free shipping shipstation
dot-com click on the lo microphone at
the top of the page type in Whitney say
it again
Whitney that station comm enter offer
code Whitney ship station make ship
happen it's away on you airy 2012
January 22 Monday the year 2020 shows up
a lot in science fiction a lot of people
you know predicted that by now we'd be
teleporting to work or living on Mars
now that happened thank God we were lied
to but we're always wrong about the
future which is why we need to get life
insurance right
that's where policy genius can help I
need life insurance you don't have life
insurance I don't think so and I know
that you're plotting my death what
happens when you die
I don't you have life insurance Janis oh
wow who pays for good policy genius that
makes finding the right insurance a
breeze in minutes you can compare quotes
from the top insurers and find your best
price you could say fifteen hundred
dollars or more by using policy genius
to compare life insurance policies
this is grace you don't get scammed once
you apply policy genius their team will
handle all the paperwork all the red
tape oh yeah
policy genius doesn't make life
insurance easy does it just also help
you find the right home and auto
insurance or a disability ensure they
make it all easy so of your
science-fiction dreams for 2020 still
haven't become a science fact don't get
discouraged listeners get life insurance
it just takes a few minutes to find your
best price at policy genius calm do it
for your dogs so that they have money
when you die policy genius will always
get the future wrong better get life
insurance right
I loved forever oh that was a blast I
loved it so much and it really I watched
it at a time where I was really confused
about the concept of marriage and
forever and all that and like I've
always been in this tussle with myself
it's like marriage was invented but the
life expectancy was 30 and why would we
expect anyone in here every stress and
my family's life has been around
divorced and falling out of love with
someone or you know and I just was and
it just kind of came at the perfect time
yeah when the writers came up with the
title because we didn't have a title fro
even when we were shooting it there was
no title Oh interesting
and when when they first presented it to
to us with Maya Rudolph
they were like forever and we're like
what does that mean exactly but then
they sort of explained like because is
it forever yeah you know is that a
positive thing or not so oh yeah I was I
love doing I mean doing anything with
Maya Rudolph - I can't I get to see her
a lot these days it's really things have
worked out where we get to work together
all the time
she's a very musical person yes well no
I mean just like mad crazy genius do you
like doing podcast I felt really guilty
asking you doing it to do this I hate it
I hate every moment of it first of all
microphones drive me crazy I get there
and even in TV no it's it's great it's
um I like it it's kind of like this new
art form I really and in the beginning
it was very um sort of you know measured
out like you know do you want to do this
part now I like that it's like the
floodgates are open and ya doing it and
and it's great so I also as corny as it
sounds I you know I get to see you we
get to talk a little bit you know it's
it's a nice thing I do think are there
like stages of our relationships should
be televised yes we should only hang out
on camera yes only document yes
our budding relationship and even into
old age where we're like 87 and
yeah whatever whatever whatever those
cameras are gonna be then I also love
Stanford drummers because I think
everybody and I'd be really interested
in people's reaction to this I think
when you go oh if I were to do a special
for just one group of people who would
it before that's a great life hack to
find out who you are oh yeah isn't that
it maybe you're like what would might be
for that you know like an anger
management class or I think mine would
be like stand up for a coin therapists I
mean it would be like it really made me
hold up a mirror to myself yeah I mean I
say go for it stand up for podcasters
would be kind of funny I have lots of
notes oh yeah
what do you mean like listening to you
know just like because I've had to do so
many podcasts
you mean like other people of other
people it's just like a full-time job to
do other people's mind casts so maybe
that but I do think it's a good exercise
for anyone who's kind of trying to
figure out who they are you realize what
you're good at
yeah and what do you not like about what
without you know being specific what's
something that podcasters do sometimes
they do whatever drive you crazy when
did you get into comedy oh boy it's like
oh boy someone can find that I it's kind
of a waste of how you ask me that how
can you ask me that question now when
did you learn to drive today you know
it's it's a I don't know 17 I still
don't have an answer for it by the way
it's like a bad childhood I don't know
next question like why are you I got me
something that people can find 50 other
places interesting or people not doing
research or something and being like
what's the new special called and you're
like why did I Drive to van eyes for
this yeah could you google it could I
hold document written out for you look
at it it's called Fred are you did I do
my research you got me this record I got
you a record come on vintage Bad Brains
record we were talking about Washington
DC because in the days when I was in a
band I'm dressing the cameras when I was
in a band we really admired the
Washington DC punk scene so and copied
all those bands and our singers from DC
but we lived in Chicago and but Fugazi
minor threat lungfish
Serkis lupus we just loved Dischord
records
that's right worse and loved it all and
I've been to DC so me really had you
been to the 9:30 club 9:30 both versions
that's the early version and the new
version and the black hat and I just
yeah
DC is like a real center point of that
girl sonic highways operate just like
perfectly sums it up if you guys want to
learn about it yeah but uh I I'm so
curious this is a weird question to ask
but I'm just I try to ask questions that
I don't know the answer to what in your
life when you spend money what helps
what works meaning like what is worth
spending money on first-class plane
ticket yep great answer because it
hotels and and yeah and plane tickets is
like why skimp on mm-hmm your life
comfort and self care insanity yeah yeah
I'm a better person when I'm at a hotel
where I can sleep yeah it's the key I
actually think it's in a weird way it's
saving money on health mm-hmm that's
right and that's right and and it
doesn't come from I hope it doesn't come
from a place of bragging about money no
I'm not saying I'm just saying that that
Coach ticket to go to whatever country
if that's all that's in the cards I
actually think it's not worth the trip
is what I'm saying I'm just saying try
to take care of yourself yeah and
there's a you this is really ignorant
for me to say but I'm like you can
afford it you can find it yeah find
there's a way to find those tickets and
drink Starbucks for six months yeah I
mean I guess I think throughout my life
even when I was in a band I tried to
take care of myself I did try to find
whatever motels I did try to sort of
have a car I I and it's such a weird
thing to say I'm just saying for me
mm-hmm
I'm like how you know how much is this
ticket I'm gonna go for it but you also
know you're gonna be the best version of
yourself so for me it's like I'm gonna
stay in a nice hotel so I'm my best at
the show that you guys paid money for
actually I owe you this I owe you the
eight-hour rest of
yourself I used to think it was so
glamorous to like you know stay in the
shittiest hotels and might fly the
shittiest airline yeah be exhausted and
like I was like I only had two hours of
sleep I was a new rock star like nothing
punk-rock about that
no and you pay for it you do if with
your health and your your grumpiness pay
and collagen yeah you seem so healthy to
me well that's a nice seem like you
really take care of yourself your mental
well mentally and emotionally I do I
wish I was better at avoiding sweets
uh-huh I wish I was better at exercise
what's your suite of chocolate really
just straight-up chocolate bar yeah just
like during the day yeah I I do it in a
way that's like I feel it's not healthy
it's not like oh I enjoy a little bit of
talked about I um my feeling towards
sweets is one that's like I would say is
like I don't know if that's the right
attitude yeah this sort of like after a
show this is like um I feel like when I
started stand-up people were like dying
of alcoholism you know and you know drug
use and now we're like I need to eat
less that's it's still like yeah for our
purview like for our world it's still
pretty good given what I I agree you
know I agree I think yeah people do seem
very comic I know it's like vegan now
thank you like SoulCycle pilates like I
feel like too many people died yeah I
think we watched enough people died that
people started pulled together I I see
less delusion I see um less defensive
nurse like what yeah I actually do see
my friends people I know are making
changes in their lives and that's kind
of a really and it's a pretty it's sad
that has to come to this but it's a
pretty quick how something reverberates
like I remember when it was like Patrice
and Geraldo those guys like a bunch of
people got sober after that yeah and
then even within the last six months
after Brody died a lot of my friends are
like you know I think I'm gonna go to
antidepressants and start getting to
therapy yeah like it just was like right
away yeah you know as opposed to just
distancing yourself and I don't know
what whatever his problem was
it's actually people go towards it yeah
you know talking about Brody and sharing
about Brody that's right I think a lot
of people had opened a lot of people's
eyes but it is funny to just hear like
my biggest problems chocolate ya know
yeah but I feel happy so um I'm not
gonna go searching through my mind for
what I feel is unhealthy yeah but I feel
pretty happy I love being in LA even
though I've got to travel a lot I love
LA so much nobody says that and it makes
me so happy to me the biggest problem in
LA are the people who complain about it
no it's I hate leaving it me too he did
it I love it here and in terms of like
the shad they're shallow people there's
shallow people everywhere I don't I also
don't know what that means and I don't
know what phony means what I don't
understand this thing that people are
looking for right I think that it
depends on the choices you make if
you're going out to the club every night
and I you know I don't know what that is
I think a lot of it is people's
projection I think it's their insecurity
I think if you do what we do maybe not
in your trajectory nough so there's just
so much rejection involved and it
probably just wounds people the way they
justify it is these fake-ass phony
motherfuckers they don't know you know I
think it's just a charity and fear I
think it's also that it's a City and
people expect there to be people around
all the time so you've got to kind of
make the effort a little bit to like
find your friends and make time for
people but that so I think that's what
you know we're all at home comfortable
so I think that's what people are
reacting to yeah you're in a good
relationship with it yeah someone that I
love you guys are buddies she's another
person who I feel like we're very very
close even though I don't get to see her
that much yeah she's like an instant
family / yeah we just vibrate on a
similar frequent but I could see that
you guys have that we're very similar in
all your ways where were you raised DC
DC we just talked about no this is my
least favorite so what's it like being a
woman in comedy oh boy it's just like
what's it like me what's it what's it
like being a woman anywhere what are you
are you talking about I it's too bad
that people decide
have a podcast they have a microphone
and they're still that's and that's it
that's your thing now now there's
nothing I can say that's not gonna be
problematic because if I say like it's
fine I work hard I'm hard for men to if
it's hard for all of us to tell you yeah
like you wanted like me to someone like
what do you what do you want out of this
question there's like no way that I can
answer this question yeah and if you did
any research you would know that I've
answered this question 50 times yeah
just makes me irate I feel like Natasha
like I would never think to put you guys
together but now that you're together I
cannot picture of better pairing well
we've known each other a while I mean
we're friends before yeah I knew her
Maya introduced me to where ages ago
can you believe the early 2000s this so
long ago um so I've known her a while
but I think that I've never done that
I've never dated someone that like I
knew for a while um was there just like
never you guys were always with other
people yeah yeah and it's you know it's
one of those things that we're both not
idealistic mhm so when we got together I
think we were both a little bit like uh
we'll see how this goes oh that's so as
opposed to this is it here we go yeah
there's a little bit
all right we're you know we're both
crazy and I think that sort of
day-to-day is kind of what you know well
you didn't have these oppressive
suffocating expectations on it
exhaustible expectations or each other
yeah crazy
and here we aren't I don't know if
you're crazy to me well crazy I'm
singing in a very light I decide I'm the
b-side yeah you know I think that
sometimes when people are self-aware
they come off crazy or whatever that
were people take the license to call
them crazy it's like just because I
advertise my flaws that's the same as
thing you can do
yeah it's admit that you're crazy oh
yeah the craziest people are the ones
that are like no I'm the best
oh that's bad news you know yeah anyone
who's edifying themselves and examining
themselves are the ones that call
themself good those are only people I
trust yeah if people are saying like I
figured it out I'm good
yeah like that's not to be classed in
every day is it hard with how busy you
both are how do you oddly well you know
there there are hardships about it yeah
but um it seems because we're both busy
mm-hmm I think there's something about
it that seems okay yeah there are
logistical things we've got to deal with
but then I think we've gotten you even
used to that do you try to go no days
without talking you mean like like do
you try to check in every like if you're
both on different oh yes you try to go
like we check in every day oh yeah but
it's not that's not a matter of trying
it so we just end up you naturally end
up doing and yeah I just for some reason
like watching Russian dog gave me
anxiety just thinking about the schedule
I know I know
even I know even in writing it they were
they as you know writes do they're just
they disappear into it so her schedule
was yeah really intense but she's so
like you know self-aware and clear and
knows what to do but I have trashed a
couple relationships because I was like
oh I'll just put work first and the best
thing I can do is just like do all this
work and I'll talk to you tomorrow like
you have to carve out the time yeah but
I mean you know fact that gets in the
way
sure mm-hmm because I'm not saying like
oh we you know every day we do have to
sort of we figure things out yeah so
yeah I understand what you mean by that
definitely I would not want to be in a
fight with Natasha if I were to pick
like the top three people I wouldn't
want to get in a fight with it would be
bilborough's probably my number one huh
myself is number two and Natasha is like
number three but here's that I think
she's good to get into a fight with you
would want to get into a fight really
cuz yeah because you start a fight she
talks things out well if you were in a
fight with her yeah she actually would
confront it not in a confrontational way
but itself she talks things through and
I think she has a good way even if at
first she's angry of figuring out where
the other person is coming from so when
she's an arguments with people she does
actually go towards it which is a very
healthy thing yeah
as opposed to I know other people who
are shut down that's right and we're
done that's right and that's and I can't
see your side yeah I've you know uh you
know we will always have a problem that
back that's not a good approach in my
opinion now but Natasha actually goes
towards problems to at least express
herself and also to try to fix it
yeah to me that's so interesting yeah
because she's so self-aware too but also
so empathic like we you know have had
some friends in common and we're able to
talk she actually really helped me in a
moment where I wasn't having compassion
she's able to go like yeah but that
person just goes through this and
they're saying yes their parents dropped
the ball
like she can really empathize with
someone that's doing something hurtful I
yes I hurt people hurt people and she
doesn't have the tools like she'll
empathize with someone she's turned
around my opinion on a situation wow I
thought I knew there was a band when
there's a music one not in a band that
I'm in that I was sort of and this is a
while ago
that she sort of explained to me like
well you know there was yeah it's just
explained to me someone's point of view
that now maybe they're feeling hmm it
was someone who had a family in the band
anyway so it was a way that I it really
turned me I was it really just I was
like oh my god you're so right I was
talking about something and she was just
like well I guess all we can do is
forgive them you're just like shit yeah
most like Jedi you're like black belt
compassion yeah cuz that is the only way
to stay sane if you're carrying
resentments around people it's just
gonna give you cancer like it's just so
obvious approach absolutely and it took
me so long to figure that out because I
can be such a people pleaser and I feel
like I am too nice to people most of the
time but forgiveness and being fake-nice
are two different things
mm-hmm forgiveness is a tough one it's a
motherfucker it really is I think that
your success in life as a person is
directly correlated to how quickly you
can just forgive people oh yes if you
start hanging on to stuff it's like it
kills you I think it kills you it's
drinking poison and expecting the other
person to die 101
just this thought in your head news it's
like it's really not good I can't
picture you angry oh yeah come on I
can't put like what makes you like what
like grinds your gears I mean it's too
detailed to like if I start trying to
explain it I'm going to sound like a
crazy person next to me you're let's put
it in the category of why is it everyone
thinking like I am so if I'm in a group
situation my way right this this cool
way that I've got why are we all
thinking this way and wait if everyone
thought like fred armisen the world
would be a cooler place to be fair I
want everyone to think like you I don't
know that's very nice but I think when
you know come on with the flow is this
yes and someone's not that way that then
I start getting resentful but I'm saying
that I'm saying that that is wrong for
me to do i do that i get i get very
inflexible as well social situations
especially like i was at a party last
night and i remember like the car every
time the conversation we got about
politics i was just like why are we I
kept trying to change the subject
instead of just walking away and
starting something new like I found
myself like I'm like the one of those
Australian herding dogs I gonna try to
get everyone to do what I want to do you
do huh and talk about what I want to
talk about yeah I definitely do that and
I try to just be a passenger and just
let it happen
you know I was at a party last night and
this is so bratty of me and a lot of
people were talking about work stuff
like Hollywood stuff and I was like oh
no this is our night off let's talk
about other stuff but people were like
what about this writer for this thing
and what about this did you express this
no no no no I just see but you were
angry or whatever I felt unseen yeah I I
was just like how are we not in my mind
how are we not in my paradigm that's
exactly my problem so yes I've done that
in work situations I show up I'm like I
know there's a script but come on we
improvise we think of cool stuff that's
like no we stick to the script that you
know people have other ways of doing
things so I'm sorry that you you know
you came from this other thing I'm sort
of yelling at myself
like this is not this is not that
production this is a different one I had
a really mind-bending situation happened
where I was working with someone that
just worked very differently than me yes
like like in the production though like
fly by the seat of their pants like
casting people the day of like just very
people like doing it that way yeah maybe
it's it's part of their adrenaline thing
or they work well under pressure which I
think I work well under pressure but I
like to plan as much as possible cuz you
know things are gonna go wrong
the day that you can't control so I just
try to control as much as I can even if
it's a false sense of control just so I
feel like I could go and be emotionally
free and not because I can't do
logistics and creativity at the same
time uh-huh like I can't like go do a
scene and then be like okay now we need
to company move and like I I try to just
only be creative but I'm being creative
okay
and I was working with this person and I
find I said this is a dysfunctional work
situation this is dysfunctional action
yeah it was on an email well because no
one please I know I know you're coming
I'm on my look isn't like how dare I'm
like I know nobody knew it was like the
emails every like which everyone should
be seeing on an email so everyone knows
what was going on yes the kind of thing
thank you yeah where everyone I had to
tell five people the same thing instead
of just what so I was like can we all
get on a group email so that we're all
just getting the information at the same
time and our ones on the same page and
can we start like getting ahead of
casting like casting a couple days in
advance you know just kind of stuff like
that I like to just sort of be ahead of
things and I'm in somebody explain to me
like it's dysfunctional for you this
person thrives in that and it blew my
mind that anyone would work differently
than me yeah but we're like emailing on
a Saturday like I'm just like no we
should finish on Friday so that you know
can have their weekend yes and I was it
blew my mind that my way wasn't the only
way yes dammit
rehearsals up I've gotten mad about
rehearsals how come you like them or
don't
oh um I'm making exactly the same point
again where like a music thing what I'm
like you know rehearsals are at 11:00
we're prac time like why ma'am we're
just come on we're musicians I'm like
that's you know why am i mad at the fact
that they want to practice I'm agreeing
I'm just I just restated you're exactly
yeah that's a really hard thing for me I
mean I would imagine I mean you've
worked with so many you just have to
what turn it over who when you're in
that situation yes okay it's just a
simple thing of like let go of those
resentments and then the end of the day
comes I mean literally you know I mean
it was great it was fine yeah
yeah I oh I remember I don't know if you
ever toured and did like radio with your
band in the early days of Portland India
we had to do a lot of radio really yeah
just around the country or like Foner's
Foner's and like sort of arriving in one
building and there's like one thing it
right after that no yeah that's wild
yeah do you remember Mancow of course
really Chicago I remember in when I was
the first time ever is touring I went
and did Mancow and a band showed up and
I cuz I was like oh my god it's 5:00
a.m. that's the worst and I remember
just being like if I was with four other
people right now that's the only thing
that would be more frustrating oh you
would find it frustrating like just the
idea of like someone's late like they
were fighting cuz one person was late
yeah and I remember going it just takes
one person to make this a nightmare yeah
you all do all have to be similar I feel
like I'd be oasis if I was in a band
dealing with other people is oh it has
to be a personality fact whenever I see
that band's breakup now I'm more like oh
I get it
I'm surprised more don't I mean getting
food yeah cuz that was before that your
radio thing you should see what they
were like
I don't even know what Banyon talking
about after oh no they came in they were
all fighting and resentful and one
person was late one person was hungover
or one person like didn't have their
milk and what this fucking guy like it's
like a marriage with four people and
then after Blake are we done we're gonna
go eat I don't know I'm gonna go I'm not
hungry I mean you guys a healthy place I
thought you said I don't want John for
that's not Chuck they have other options
there and then well I'm going downstairs
Oh
yeah I can't that would drive me insane
I think they married to four people oh
yeah
and it's looking at faces all day in a
car I remember seeing the Eagles last
concert at the Forum why I went to that
but they all came on stage at different
times yeah I think they must swore in
separate buses no they do they've
separate planes and I remember just
being like oh this is what a dramatic
entrance like look at that like
choreographing a dramatic entrance
they're like no they don't speak they
walk on stage at different times and do
not engage with each other somehow u2 is
the only band that seems like they're
all friends really to me and they're
still together yeah they hang same
members right no there's a point where
you're so rich where you have to just
like I added I'm sort of over people
having bad attitudes when they work like
this is like music and our business is
the only time we ever have like an
excuse to just like still be assholes
and still I know I know
you there's no excuse anymore no bad
attitude also bad attitude is we could
feel it always it's really got something
I'm resentful of of other people being
angry I'm always like this is your
problem
your anger is your problem I know a lot
of people recently was had a thing with
someone and someone's like yeah but he's
miserable he's a miserable person I'm
like that's not my problem
why why do i why is that on me yeah he's
just I but look he's miserable like yeah
I make excuses yeah you know you can and
this is why Natasha I feel like is so
good at delineating the difference
between enabling someone's behavior and
forgiving like what I always struggle
with that yeah yeah I'm here so that I'm
so angry I know there's also that little
thing of like liking the drama a little
bit like if someone's really mad on set
I'm like oh why are you so mad I kind of
like it it's also a way because we all
like recreate our childhood
circumstances and yes that someone
always becomes the dad and then the
drunk mom yeah like as always there is
something sexy about it you know but
it's the only the kind of drama I want
like you have to have your drama but be
on time yeah you know yeah and deliver
but there's I find that the you it's
usually I'm the most talented people
don't do shit like that yes I feel the
most
the most talented people it's I I try to
focus on like what their behavior is and
it because they're always the best
always will arrow seems like this like
professional walks into a room greatest
and it's it's there is it's just
everyone's relaxed I think if like you
Maya
Kristen will like Steve Carrell like the
there's this thing that like you know
really helped me because I think for a
long time I romanticized craziness and
anger and I thought it was a necessity
in order to be funny and I always looked
at you guys to just go oh like no that's
not true that's a myth that's just a way
to justify shitty behavior yeah you know
you you can be emotionally well-adjusted
and healthy and funny yes you know that
that it can happen that like in stand-up
was very much I think for a long time
how we all justified are like justified
bad behavior yeah I think it's just how
we are we're comments yeah you know like
we don't sweetie you knew what you were
signing up for
like that's yeah not okay
[Music]
2020 this is the year that you explore
new skills the roaring 20s deepen
existing passions get lost in creativity
this is the year skill shares online
classes are gonna make this happen for
you what you might you just might find
what surprises and inspired I got too
excited I really do love this company
it's an online learning community where
millions get together to take their next
step in their creative is yearn a with
thousands of inspiring classes for
creative and curious people on topics
like illustration design photography
video freelancing more you name it
they've got it skill share is an online
learning community that offers
membership with meaning you can do
whatever you want I can do it a trial
you can take a class on stuff and get
smarter whenever you want with the
support of fellow creative skill Sharon
powers you to accomplish real growth
that's called countability that's what I
need I need someone like affordable
college mmm-hmm
offers classes designed for real life so
you can move your creative journey
forward without putting life on hold you
can do it whatever you want this this is
what I hate about school is that you had
to do it on their time yeah and what
they wanted to talk about I don't I'm
not just creative when you tell me I'm
creative I have to be able to decide
when I'm
learn its credibly affordable less than
$10 a month for an annual prescription a
class that I have had my eye on I want
to do the it's called a Productivity
masterclass create a custom system that
works if you've got any more productive
you'd be a robot
I'd be my own robot I produce robot I
can take some class maybe plunk hurry up
skill sure is a proud sponsor of good
for you explore your creativity at
Skillshare comm slash good for you and
get two free months of premium
membership that's two whole months of
unlimited access to thousands of classes
for FRA get free so get started today by
heading to Skillshare comm slash good
for you I love this better with you
better with you look at that this may be
a song this is my two favorite things
peanut butter and whiskey Wow it's
called screwball whiskey no matter how
many times you say it it sounds like an
oddball combination but don't let a
thing like preconceived notions fool you
peanut butter whiskey is where it's at
it's warm it's welcoming aroma
deliciously smooth peanut butter whisky
God did you taste this yeah you can't
taste it on camera look away
oh but some people are listening to this
can I smell it on camera yeah I think oh
oh my gosh it smells exactly like peanut
butter that's the one thing I think when
I drink whiskey I'm like but I kind of
wish I was eating peanut butter yeah cuz
some ways now you don't have to pick
yeah that's great oh you know some way
seemed to be a little gasoline eeee
oh really yeah and that is you know you
can do put this in coffee I bet this
would be delicious and coffee or on a
big scoop of like vanilla ice cream in
coffee that would be really good to make
like an adult dessert like an adult root
beer float yeah yeah in like a milkshake
the I would put coat and then peanuts in
it it's very southern the patent
ground-up peanuts no you just poured by
a pack of peanuts in coke okay well
that's insane it's delicious you should
try it right well there is a reason why
screwball recently won a double gold
medal award best in class for best
flavored whiskey it's this a winner it's
the number one whiskey there's a whiskey
class yes at the 21 I don't know it's a
it's the bits of competition want to go
20 19 New York world wine and spirits
competition for this it once two years
in a row okay well this we have a winner
screwball the original and Moe
rewarded peanutbutter whiskey is now
available nearly everywhere at 70 proof
screwball whiskey peanut butter whiskey
is the perfect shot or perfect addition
to your favorite cocktail pick it up at
your local store ask for it and your
favorite bar or restaurant ready to
hashtag get screwed go to screwball
whiskey Dom for more info drink
responsibly
obviously advertisement by screwball
spirits LLC san marcos CA whiskey with
national flavors and caramel color 35
percent alcohol by volume I think I have
to say that part right when did you get
started in why are you making me do math
yeah also what answer is gonna be
exciting I don't know when I was 20
literally no one wants to hear that no
it's not information on YouTube there
are like pandas dancing to Beyonce no
one cares when I started comedy where'd
you grow up no one cares yeah there's
nothing there's nothing interesting
you're making me be boring and then I'm
gonna just go through it quickly because
I've answered the question so many times
now I'm boring now I'm bombing on your
podcast yeah in Culver City I don't want
to be here that shit makes me nuts I'm
trying to think of anything else in
podcasts that drive me crazy it's all
fine I find there's a lot of some of
them said I dunno can you get Lena and
closer oh there's that can you there's
like you can't even closer yeah it's
been pretty part I don't like if
everyone's you know who I'm talking
about I don't like when there's so many
signs around me that I like walked into
your billboard for your show oh yes
there's like a fish with the person's
name on it that's not cool and like a
street sign with their last name and I'm
like in your abs that's not yes yeah
there's a lot of that yeah there's a lot
of this is this something I don't mind
but I do notice a lot of inside jokes so
they'll be like some sort of a teddy
bear
that's Reginald and we all hold Reginald
hand we come in like what happened yeah
there's some
and then when you ask what the inside
joke is your the hassle yeah like you're
the nuisance yes it's reginal it's a
spare and then all of our viewers know
it I also don't let I also stop doing
some podcast because I realize like you
also do have to listen to an episode
before you go on yeah for some of them
like I did a podcast where every episode
they ask like five questions it's the
same yes five yeah and I was super
stumped and they're like you know listen
the show do you and I was like I'm can't
be mad at you I came here I'm here how
do I owe you more time know that I'm
already giving they can't be mad like
here these are the five questions and I
couldn't come up with an answer which
means I wasn't like prepared plus for
that podcaster over it is someone not
coming up with an answer sometimes I
think that's entertaining
I think so too to see so do you want me
to just be like oh you prepared I mean I
think the beauty of this is you're
actually seeing how people's minds work
yeah you know but I was in like a
perfectionist expiry about it yeah
it took me a long time though to do
podcast and not try to be funny cuz I
thought I've just been conditioned to
believe you just have to be funny all
the time and that's all anyone want to
would want to hear from me yeah
so it took me a long time after like
doing Marin and Brogan and stuff but
like they just want to hear people
having conversations and I'm like why
like it took me a long time to
understand it is it is fun listening to
people have a car i la I love it if
there's something soothing about it yeah
what do you listen to what I am well
there's there's one called the trap set
which is a drummer one oh and they don't
play the drums on it they just talk to
drummers and it's just I find it
I just love every word of it I'm gonna
pronounce his name wrong but there's a
drummer with a podcast you're gonna know
exactly who it is I might not know you
I'm going to look at your laptop no I
this is the first time I'm using my
laptop I'm trying not to use papers and
I this is I seem so crazy because I'm
trying not to like do ASMR with papers
it's funny that we have these mints here
because none of us are I'm not gonna
have a mint
I'm recording why not I just have him
there because I always feel like I have
coffee breath
ready Vinnie you - say it wrong
Kelly you de oh he's a legend yeah he's
got a podcast he does yes and they're
like ten minute episodes he called
breakfast with Minnie he is like I have
a I have a thought that he should
actually go into acting because he's
such a character he's accent he adds a
very East Coast there's something about
him he's look like he's in at the very
instant the credits of the stand-up for
dreamers really there's a part where I'm
in a music store it's after the credits
with Clem Burke my favorite drummer and
in him and he I think he should be an
actor please listen to his paws the
spelling of his name
I always if I was if I was on Ellis
Island I'd be like I'm proudly gonna
change this in front of everyone
The Vow I'm like and it's an Italian
name already someone just it's okay for
you it always looks wrong it just when I
type it cuz I was - what is it what is
the actors I don't know the actual
spelling see oh L hey I you da nothing
right about this Callie you de Kalu de
Kalu de I would change the first the
first two vowels I would see I would you
CA I mean I like that we're just
pitching on new names for someone who's
had his we should have him on I don't
know I just wanna tell him like also
there's changing your name you know I'm
not listen he's a legend I'm nothing
against it like just saying somewhere
down the line I remember when I first
moved to LA everyone was like is that
your stage name coming so I'm like you
think I would pick that if I was gonna
pick a name I'd pick that it's a great
name do a lot of people you think well
Johnny Ramone is John Cummings right is
he yeah really
that's one to embrace really okay I
think it's probably a part of why I got
funny because people I had to defend
myself so young from jokes about it
that's like cum jokes uh-huh I got so
many caught in case you are yeah sure
what people were making fun of uh did
you get made fun of us again
Oh Jed I can't made fun of that really I
don't think so really made fun of no
Lily yeah I'm not saying about like you
know I had a billion friends and I was
like but I'm just saying made fun of I
don't not like made fun of made fun of
yeah I feel like I had like a brutal
just because of the last name coming and
I was too tall too young I was like 510
at like nine Wow I was like the weirdo
but I really want you this is the
made-up story but i was 5-9 how am i I
must have been eight years old then I
shrank but but in my teen years I
strength then we'll just thank God do
you feel like people always expect you
to be funny mmm do you feel pressure no
I don't feel any pressure um I also
don't walk around thinking like am such
a funny guy
really oh yeah that's probably why
you're funny it's part of it not the
only reason obviously yeah but I don't
know no pressure you feel so you're so
like it's so interesting like after
listening to this I'm not even to try to
say it again Vinnie see we're calling
him Vinnie see now this drummer he was
talking about commitment here's a
podcast on commitment and how drumming
is ultimately about commitment because
you can't set you can't be anywhere
except there and you have to be
committed to what you're doing a hundred
percent oh that's crazy that you got
it's it's I think only like 15 minutes
long
and I was thinking about it and I know
people always talk about the
similarities between drumming and comedy
music and comedy but to me I was like oh
it kind of boils down to commitment more
than anything
wow we should find him and bring him
back that's a really good point
I saw drumming because there are a lot
of drummer comedians I saw it
differently now that's great I saw it I
don't mean as opposed to I'm saying I
saw the role of a drummer in a band
isn't very much like someone in a sketch
is like it because drummers in the back
right seated but you're still getting
attention playing cymbals and stuff
there's this like sort of look at me but
don't look at me yeah and like I'm gonna
make the most noise yeah
hiding yes and there's something in a
sketch where I feel like there's a
similarity in your role with a group
isn't the drummer kind of like the
heartbeat of the band um it's that fair
to say it depends I love you Fred cuz
you just think about what you're gonna
say before you say it I say something
and then I'm like that true it's because
do you think I figured out later
it's cuz English is my second language
so I don't know the word that you mean
for it no but I think that um drumming
it depends on the drummers so some
drummers like Keith Moon mm-hmm they
weren't the heartbeat they were just
making such a spectacle of drumming that
they're it's almost like they're like
the window dressing but yes a lot of
times rolling stones a lot of bands the
draw but I do find that sometimes the
bass players the real heartbeat where
he's out the song really does fall apart
it's not even a song anymore right
oh my god I'm explaining music and piano
as chords chords are notes put together
an instrument I'm so I apologize for
that I think all comedians secretly just
want to be musicians or rock stars and
the vice-versa
definitely yeah definitely definitely
did you ever see that New York Times
article that said the 36 questions it'll
make you fall in love with anyone no oh
I wonder if you told me about this
really I think you brought it up
seriously
me I I have a my recollection is I
remember I was away that's right there's
that maybe it was just on that tour
stick in the green room no on that tour
someone brought it okay it'd be weird if
I had brought I wasn't you it was
someone in in in the crew that was like
yes trying to like doing it yeah I
thought I'd ask you a couple questions
from it shouldn't see if we fell in love
Natasha don't panic I promise I've it's
impossible to fall in love with me if
someone's in love with you what does
friendship mean to you as one of them
what does friendship mean to me ma
friendship is something that happens but
as a past tense like way in the like
chip is when I look back meaning like
friendship to me is like oh I've known
this person for 10 years huh I think
that's my friend oh wow that's not
always the case but I'm saying that
that's the friendships most meaningful
to me are sort of looking back like I
said that great
that's a friendship that we have what's
let's take Maya for example what's this
thing that we have we work together oh
wait a minute
ah that's a friendship that's so good
but it's not exclusive I'm saying this
is a friendship yeah well but it's gonna
be fun I think for us too in 10 years
we're like hey remember remember
microphone is that when we take now they
have these other devices that these like
crystals that's float oh that's right
we'll just have me record sound that'll
be cool shark tank patent bat oh damn it
I feel like friendship actually you guys
did a sketch about this cancel it which
is to me that's like a codependence yes
I would like send that to my codependent
friends yes as like a bits I cancel it
it's like that is like they should play
that at the beginning of every al-anon
yes stay like two codependence that is
funny but also like should be taught in
schools yeah but that's usually when I
realize someone's my friend when I can
reschedule something or cancel something
oh so that's your answer
mm-hmm yes so in ease we're fine there's
no scorecard and you will let me be
authentic and I don't feel pressure and
you'll understand if I cancel something
yes remember last night I was trying to
make you cancel today for us to be
better friends oh but I think you were
worried that I was gonna I found it a
hassle I was I was I was in a like panic
about a pleasure
um what would constitute a perfect day
for you um
wake up really early really like you
know six or seven coffee great nuts
almond milk
blueberries think just alone time Oh
ring quiet then I think Natasha I think
quiet uh yeah
and then some sort of a work thing
during the day mm-hmm today is kind of
you know even though this is friendship
this is also a type of work I can make
this feel more like work so the fact
that life sort of got up and I drove
yeah and I went to a place with
equipment makes it a perfect day me too
you know elements of music and comedy so
this is like the makings of a perfect
day so somewhere in there what about you
that is so wonderful because I I know I
get shamed a lot for it I work a lot
mmm I love it I get satisfaction out of
it I need it I actually went to a
workaholics Anonymous meeting once and
because I do think my life was getting
there was one point where I think I was
doing like three shows and like couldn't
say no to things it was like doing
charity events on the weekends and I've
really heard saying time saying no to
friends like when friends have shows
like I want to you know help them win
and I was just I was getting sick all
the time and I went to a workaholic
Anonymous meeting and I remember it was
so funny because everyone was late like
30 minutes sketch really it really has
got there no joke there were a lot of
known people there the first thing
everyone said to each other was like
love your work we're just like the worst
thing you can say it over coholic are
like no I mean like if you did less of
it it'd be fine like I don't need you to
like it was everyone was putting their
foot in their mouths and a bunch of
people left early people were like
taking calls the whole time it was like
and then at the end of every 12-step
meeting they say you know you do it this
thing called the stronger brand than you
do it works if you work it and you're
worth it and the word work is in there I
I didn't know that they change it for
the workaholics Anonymous meeting so it
was like it's a serenity prayer and then
it works and you're fabulous and I yell
that it works if you work it and they
like pulled me aside but I doing some
kind of work just I always I always need
on some level and this is kind of the
perfect I never thought I would have a
podcast like there's no I'm not putting
on a wig and making stuff yeah you know
all that's done yeah so it's like work
but nights there's a relaxed being
around animals is a big part of me
having a perfect day when animal I have
a rescue horse oh yes I remember
so I'll go see him and he puts me in my
Comus space because he's the happiest
when I'm you know prey animals when
you're calm they're happy so he'll show
me what's going on I'll show me if I
have too much anxiety or you know if I'm
just like out of line or not being
present so I could to like surrendered
or whatever's going on with him so that
always makes me feel very happy and then
I'll Chum times go on a hike in your
yeah we shouldn't disclose where you are
so you know for two here in Florida
someone put my last address on Reddit
and I had to move so please don't do
that again
if you could change anything about the
way you were raised what would it be I
get white this makes people fall in love
it makes them trauma bond that's what
this test is I'm uh although I mean I
could just brag and just be like we just
it was too good we'd have less money
yeah we had less money and less
presidents like a smaller Christmas tree
less cars have less of an education too
much if I could change anything about
the way I was raised I think um weird
question I think I think well the food
like the I think it might have just been
the decade that I grew up in but I think
cereal and stuff was like garbage Oh
cocoa puffs Apple Jacks remember Apple
Jacks Cinnamon Toast Crunch was a
breakfast
they look like sugar it was a shake and
cinnamon it was it was actual sugar
powder yeah on a graham cracker graham
crunches what were those things grams
honey grams Golden Grahams yes who
remembered Golden Grahams Dave always do
you remember Chaka Khan Chaka Khan
Chocula remember that's a good drag name
contract killer I'm calling that benton
trade market coun shot i mean and why
they had marshmallows in them yeah and
martin sugar just those marshmallows are
just soft in
sugar I used to pick the marshmallows
out of Lucky Charms and eat them only
yeah let's have some now it's wild yeah
so you did a lot of that I would say
that somewhere in that zone trying to
think what else it's hard I think part
of what this quiz works is you're
spending so much time watching someone
think yeah you just start to get so
bored that you fall in love I I kind of
wish that I had done more activities
with my sister oh we had sort of I mean
we got along but our lives are so
separate were only two years apart huh
but when I sometimes I see families are
my siblings like well I did stuff
together and I didn't have enough of
that yeah that's a really good answer
you know most treasured memory I don't
know how to answer that
oh is that the whole question yeah
what's your most treasured memory um oh
boy it's work-related and it's which is
bad why no I'm just saying it's bad my
most treasured memory is the first time
I'm so sorry that this is so so busy why
but the first time I ever did stand-up
on TV was on Conan O'Brien Late Night
with Conan O'Brien and it was the first
time I'd ever really been on TV TV and
there was a TV camera and the red light
went on and I remember the thought of
feeling like I love this this is feeling
mm-hmm
so that's what came to my mind first I
love that so sorry why is it why is it
what is this thing now where you're like
not allowed to love working or you're
not allowed to love succeeding that is
like yeah that is a quintessential
perfect treasured memory your first time
doing a stand-up set on a talk show like
that's perfectly good like I'm the I'm
the opposite I feel like I'm such an
asshole that I've gotten um I should say
that like the first time I did The
Tonight Show yeah that actually is my
real answer is it I'm gonna make up some
bullshit thing did you ever seem like I
you know that's my real answer that's
the most just that red light I feel like
I've lost sight of how magical those
moments are yeah because yes because now
I suppose because you're you know you're
earning money doing it and it says it is
a job but people love their job
yeah that is I do I do think you know
that I my first Tonight Show was that I
remember I was a little thrown off
because they didn't use microphones and
it was my first time doing stand up
without a holding a microwave the Livan
mm-hmm and I was really thrown off who
was the host it was Jay Leno yeah
and you just went out and didn't have a
microphone and I remember being so
freaked out but I think that it actually
kind of took my mind off of it yeah so
it made me be fresh in the moment
because all of a sudden I had this one
hand free that I had never had free and
I was just like what is this appendage
like it was just like odd maybe it's
good to be thrown off a little that's it
I didn't go into my robotic distracting
little that's kind of what I liked about
it but I remember going out and just you
have this thing where you're sort of
like looking down on yourself and you're
like I remember thinking like this is it
if this doesn't make you happy you're
fucked
totally if this doesn't work we don't
have a back-up plan
yes that's what came into my head first
and your name becomes something
different your name is like this object
like someone else is saying your name
yes and you're like oh now it's no
longer you know like your personality
it's like the a name but I sometimes
have to tell myself like just be here be
here this is it yeah this is five
minutes you've been working up to there
five minutes for eight years
yeah if you can't be here there's no
hope for you yeah if you can't even
enjoy this that's a perfect answer great
last one in agreement if you're gonna
choose to become this is so wild if
you're gonna choose to become a close
friend with your partner please share
what would be important for him or her
to know wait if let me hear it again
this quiz is so bizarre if you were
going to become a close friend with your
partner wait wait so if you and Natasha
were just to become like close friends I
guess oh my as in what would be
important for her to know like this you
know I like this question because
sometimes we forget we're friends with
the person we're girlfriend of yes you
know like a thing that you could say to
a friend that you couldn't say to a
partner like I don't like you know music
in the house I actually secretly don't
but it seems she knows a lot of that
stuff well that's probably you guys are
so calm but no but I'll give you an
answer
um I think she doesn't realize how funny
how much she does make me laugh or how
like she's I would say top three
funniest people I know yeah it's easy so
be sort of like just so you know I
really did find whatever it's funny as
opposed to it being it was like it was
an obligatory laughs oh that's these are
real laughs yeah yeah just like so it's
not like I have my comedian friends and
I really laughs I was like some of these
things I got just so you know or like
are deeply funny do you ever like when
you're around t'rul enough you because I
find that the people of my life that are
really funny I just go like like I know
I know how I just sort of like it
happens with you like I just you know
don't get desensitized to it yeah I
think I tend to go like that's funny
yeah actually funny instead of laughing
yeah
there's both versions to me and there's
those things that your friends just know
is gonna kill you do you guys have the
same taste in like movies no really
uh-huh
what do you do um she's got a sort of
heightened deep love of movies from the
70s yeah I think she is to me like it
has a 70s soul yeah oh definitely
seventeen New York's yes but I find also
this with with Bill Hader and John
Mulaney there's like they have these
love for movies that I have more for
music mm-hmm and they have they take
things very personally yeah about movies
and directors and stuff and I don't have
that there are movies that I love but I
don't as the way that you feel about
yourself and music I think I'm that way
with movies interesting where there are
movies that I love but I'm not like I
don't you just seem like I don't wear
them on me I watching new movies I the
joy has been taken out of that a little
for me when it's my friends I can enjoy
it more actually even I know the person
and I know it's
but I'm in that like I need to get out
of the headspace where you're kind of
like ah that's a tr like ah they loop
that oh yes I'm the worst
there's so much of that I'm the worst
with and I'm like oh that's a reshoot
like oh they picked that up later like I
find myself going like I auditioned for
that
I guess she's good like I like it took a
little of the magic yeah out of it for
me clearly that's a wig because they're
in reshoot always yeah always my my
brain always goes there and I have a
hard time enjoying movies which is
really devastating that's okay that
maybe that's just the way that you
approach movies yeah you see that you
know that's true I like watching old
movies sometimes just cuz like we
weren't up for any of those parts it's
just like there's an innocence to them
you know do you look at billboards and
go like I was in town sometimes you see
all your friends up there you're like
yeah hope that was fun
ah yes now when you see billboards of
your friends it feels like a party you
weren't invited to yeah you know yeah
and there's so many of our friends that
do movies together and you're just kinda
like okay no whatever no I got it no I
got it whatever dude whatever
you said something I just want to for
anyone that hasn't seen stand up for
drummers I please do right now well
we're giving away if you do watch it
within the next two days where from this
podcast we're sending you seven hundred
dollars if you can prove that you see
cash up I I'm not literally I would say
one of the my favorite top ten
observations I've ever heard great
photography is a poor person proud of
something oh yeah was that something you
thought of and you were just like um
when you think that's the kind of thing
sometimes I'll think of a joke and I go
whoa
like I know that's good yeah what I did
it that was something that happened um
as I was putting this special together
is just like something I just kept
thinking and I might have said it in
conversation and someone laughed and I
think it came from there where and it's
a little bit about my own inability to
understand good photography yeah me too
so my this right so there'll be
something like the most beautiful
photographs of the year and I'm like
what am I supposed to be feeling it's a
wonderful mountaintop or or you know so
then a lot of them I saw were sort of
like sort of devastation I'm like what
you know but like it's like travel
tragedy port tragedy and but but they're
somehow proud of it so um so I it was
more about my inability to see what
great photography is I still do I still
can tell you right I cannot tell you if
something's a good photo so if I that's
if I were to like produce a photo he's
like Whitney look at this I'd be like oh
my god yes but you're only thinking but
if you think it's good I'll do it I dare
to you I guess but see the focus like uh
yeah no no I love like great it was an
accident an accidental photo because
there was a war zone and he happened oh
there's a story behind it I feel like
photography should exist on its own two
feet without your expertise it should
speak for itself exactly that's that's
my feeling about it
like if I have to know the backstory
that's a whole I don't know Photography
I'm just sort of like in LA there's so
many like photographers and I'm just
like okay alright
but get ready for people telling you hey
by the way I'm a photographer and what
you said yeah look you have and I felt
like I get so weird about that
yeah like isn't everyone I don't know I
feel like everyone thinks they're a
comedian now too so maybe that's just my
thing but I kind of that's kind of a new
thing too I think that people are doing
sort of like refined bits and using
language and I'm like it is sort of a
kicking conversation yes so you'll hear
people say things like I think they're
sort of trying to like yeah hone some
use the language of comedy I think
there's a little bit of comedy that
there's a new thing where you can do
stand-up and you it can be a different
thing so every was like hah I get it I
can yes oh there's a relay for me yeah
so I think more people is visibility
there's more athletes that want to be
comics now than ever it's like what like
and I think everyone secretly thinks
they can do it but we're not we are not
in this room we're not dissuading anyone
if you
and so I am please don't I actually have
a couple people I think that should just
quit in general there's we need to call
out the herd here it's too it's too much
with everything yeah music it goes
forever
yeah I think that you know I just think
I don't know yeah go for it I think ever
try it
see how it goes for you it's like you're
a thing of the person the audience just
let them play it out I think that's what
I mean you'll come to your own when you
realization when you hit your own brick
wall of like this isn't really doing
anything yeah I like that you give
people the dignity of their own
experience like that's so kind of you
just like no let what's your best I'd
look like if you want to be a part of
the show like let's see what you got
let's just you you need this much
attention for right now great gosh
you're so you're like so Zen I admire
your disposition you're funny you're
observation of that is funny
the last thing by the way when I look
over this way it's just that scary
someone's sitting over there right in 10
I don't want ya people are gonna watch
like what is he looking at Benton's from
Tennessee he opened for me in Tennessee
and I made him move to LA with me really
yeah
what city Nashville is where I met her
but I'm from a little town called boba
ville mm-hmm I don't know
ya know what that there's a rehab there
oh there is I've started watching this
documentary by Ken Burns about country
music oh well and country music was not
in my life but it was this documentary
is so good that it actually made me
really and now I'm just buying records
all the time Alison Krauss is probably
my favorite oh yeah she's great amazing
it's Mary Chapin carpenter is what I
like grew up on oh yeah cuz I lived in
Virginia and we always listen to Mary
Chapin carpenter and Alison Krauss
country music just has a buoyancy to it
yeah that deep it's it's really they're
telling you story it's always a story
there's always like emotion involved you
can follow there's a beginning middle
and an end
yes and it goes kind of backwards the
lyrics are sort of like here's a
statement and then the next lyric is
like well the reason for this statement
is this and that's because it's just
sort of yeah whole it just unravels oh I
love it and there's something about it
that there's this conversation on where
everyone's talked about like toxic
masculinity and stuff like country music
it's the guys hearts always broken he
always a live woman is strong yeah
there's something weirdly feminist about
country music and then you go into like
our music is like she's a ho she's a
whore yeah you know music you know
whatever the music we listen to like
country music is always like there's
something for just really triumphant
about it and something the messaging is
always like and for me watching the
documentary I found that with the
artists too there was so many female
artists that's right like huge not sort
of like well here's the female version
of country music it was like these are
artists who that's why whenever
Hollywood wants to say like there's not
women aren't being it's like it's not
like that in country music no it's not
it's not like that really part in the
right a land anyone has declined these
are legends they're running all the way
through running shit and then in I just
mean like I guess the Hollywood music or
pop maybe I mean to say it's like
everything sexist and I'm like I don't
think that's true in country music yeah
cuz Hollywood kind of picks who they're
gonna want from country like they're
like Oh protection I will take that yes
we'll let you in yeah then you become
something different you're like this
nude you're like the carry under what
all of a sudden right but I just I grew
up listening to country music it's all
strong badass women that were like I'm
leaving this man cuz you disrespected me
yeah like that was the messaging I got
there shake your titties shake your
titties like it was just like a
different thing that's most women from I
feel like older genres older genres of
music and I've said that like you know
like warmer yeah I mean like Stevie
Nicks all those people are singing about
something different than what we're
hearing that yeah they were like get
that money cash those checks like I'm my
own person
yeah that's what the country music was
that I listened to growing up yeah you
know it wasn't like go after that man I
know and then I started losing like pop
music and it was all like get the guy
that's all that matters he's the only
thing you need you the sexiest yeah I
was like weird I love country music I'm
I love that there's a new kind of music
I can find yeah strawberry wine that's
our answer
wine who's that by I do not know berry
wine
take on a song about empowerment no I
mean there's just something and there's
a I think country music always like
paints a picture and it's very
meditative for me because I can sort of
like imagine the story yeah you have to
live in country yeah that's right that's
right that's right oh that makes me
happy any other good documentaries
before I let you go to your neighbor's
house oh so I have a list of 20 of the
best documents our e30 of of best
documentaries of the last ten years no
I'm like there's so many things you do
remember that Julia Roberts moment where
she went to pick the jewelry oh yes
laughter I feel like you'd do that like
I just watched the bee from yoga
documentary did you watch that the
Bikram guy no dude will you pull up a
picture of the Bikram guy this guy is
such an epic asshole he was teaching
Bikram and is big this is the guy why is
he half naked he's the have you seen
like Bikram yoga studios you've never
seen Bikram yoga no that's like is that
the heated this guy and he was like an
egomaniacal psychopath who is a
harassing and abusing women yank that
with a sumo bun receding hairline to the
bun and would call people bitches and
called him fat and was like verbally
abusing them he had like 20 Rolls Royces
okay it's pretty wild to watch this
portrait of an egomaniac and so you say
you're using past tense as he's still
alive he's still teaching classes I
think he had to escape to Thailand
because two women accused him of rape I
think it was two in the documentary
right there might be more that's settled
but this guy there is this this is not
an anti la thing I think this is
everywhere there are these like cult
exercise instructors who get big off of
like Stockholm Syndrome like they'll
yell at you people go to exercise
classes to like get verbally abuse he's
been in some I've been in some I went to
one in an extra and that's what he does
like he yells at people like he's like
you have kimono arms get your come out
like screams and that's not I don't play
that shit I think that is a very la
thing to be like leaders tales and how
it is know in New York they do it to I
think oh well yeah I guess well people
want to just go be treated like shit
it's some weird masochistic thing or
something
and they disguised as like motivation I
don't fuck with that shit don't talk to
me that way are you unnecessary
unnecessary element me I shut down when
people yell it doesn't make me better
no I shut down I don't like being
publicly shamed and this guy tried to do
it with me and I've never done this to
someone in my life this is maybe the
most disrespectful thing I've ever done
he came over to me to come and yell in
my face and I just did that did you ever
go back to that class I did not but I've
seen him since but I almost touched his
like I almost touched it no no no reason
for it I just I didn't know what to say
cuz I don't know how you reason with
someone who's gonna go yell at an adult
that's paying them so I just did that
like yelling yeah I can't do it also
you're there already you're like I'm
here I'm I've done half they didn't
force me to come here and I dragged me
out of bed you're there I also yeah it's
times like that that I was like I wish
LA was a bunch of phony people that
bruschetta to be nice to each other like
where's that pretending to be nice thing
but this is a that's a good one I like
documentaries about like I like I love
wild wild country that was great I love
shit like that
he's an evil genius is that the pizza
bomber oh yes oh did so much I remember
when that story happened huh and I
always wanted to know what happened and
do you think she did it
I mean Hattie I mean there's it's just
the insanity in that hope
did you see the staircase yeah but only
different versions cuz it used to be on
YouTube
uh-huh yeah and so it was always
confusing like which is the official
version so yes I've seen it but I think
I've seen an old you think you did it
mm-hmm see the thing is I want to say
yes but then I don't want that to be an
official statement it's a Rorschach test
yeah whatever you answer it tells I mean
I have a very polarizing take on that I
think the owl did it okay I heard one
person one person say I agree with you
oh really yeah no wonder who he'll tell
me one day yeah after cuz I can't speak
for him but he's a comedian okay and he
wasn't doing a bit he was like I think
no I'm dead serious
yeah could not be less money and I've
done a lot of research on Al's and they
dive on people in that region and I have
owls in my yard and they come after
I also think you know life is crazy an
accident do happen and there are things
that are insane and so so my official
answer is I really don't know yeah and I
also just think and maybe I feel like I
know enough about sociopaths or uh and I
finally learned the difference between
sociopaths and Psychopaths but I think
if you've killed someone you're probably
not gonna let a camera crew in your
house for six months really good point
don't you think a really good point yes
or is that exactly what you would do but
no one made that argument all right I
don't think someone would I think
there'd be like I'm getting out of here
yeah but I do think if you're a
malignant narcissist I think that people
make assumptions like I had this crazy
thing happened like a security thing and
I had someone making death threats and I
was like we have to go after this guy
he's making death threats and the
security person was like oh the person
who's gonna kill you isn't gonna give
you warning which is not comforting but
also boy it's not the person you think
it's gonna be a new person who's
offering to help you with your groceries
yes life isn't as predictable as that
yes looks like and then yes the guy that
made the death threats ended up do it
like that's not how it works it's
someone that you're gonna see coming out
of nowhere so that kind of just like
blew my mind so I just I get obsessed
with how we project onto people and
because that guy was like a narcissistic
asshole we're like oh he did it people
thought it before they even got the
facts there was only only two I've
really been watching recently and have
you seen the woman that wasn't there
this is an older one wait did you see
that the lady with the the HBO one the
one Holmes yeah I talked about her last
night they see that's what happened last
night I only wanted to talk about that
with people at this party right the one
who like had the blood test I go into a
party with one documentary I want to
talk about and when everyone hasn't seen
it I don't know what did you think of
her that I loved her
see I do time obsessed with her and men
have done the same thing she did for
thousands of years her heart was in the
right place the technology wasn't there
yet I think I think he's a hero problem
she I don't know she's trying to do
something that's right that's right I'm
trying to do stuff we're all trying to
draw II don't
exact you know you're not allowed to
fail like she failed i-i-i think a lot
of it and i'm not the person that is
like this is sexist like i I think
people play that card too much yeah I do
think because she was kind of trying to
like ape Steve Jobs like look I think
people that tech community had it out
for her because she was just getting too
much too fast in terms of learning so I
think they all wanted her fail the what
do you want from a person I'm like I
don't know she tried to start a lab
great it's also the craziness of her the
putting on the voice and all that's the
kind that eccentric crazy is how
civilization moved forward you need
people like that yes there are that
crazy
yeah to innovate people that crazy are
the one that have vented airplanes and
building science and innovation look you
need to me that's what it sounds like
you need an eccentric ego maniac nutcase
right what did they want her to do I've
got it all
thanks for the money I've got it all
it's all figured out you know wasn't it
like a I mean it was basically like a
what we were taught as kids like make up
some fantastical fame go live your dream
go do it and she did it and we're mad at
her just remand just cuz the science
wasn't there yeah you know because of
her voice I think it's like a boat I
really do think that's what people
latched on to yeah people don't like
when people are inauthentic or lie yeah
you know but I I was all for her that's
so yeah first I think were the only two
people that are like forty meliza bit
homes yeah I was like she's ambitious if
she's a veil of shadows n't go to jail
I'll have her run my company in a
heartbeat
love her want her on my team had a sense
of moving forward yeah I'm all for and I
just admire that so much because I can
be so full of self-doubt and I'm so like
oh not me who me like I have such an
impostor syndrome that when someone I
just admire that yeah and there's a
certain level of delusion you need to
operate it in order to achieve stuff yes
I love her bro Elizabeth Holmes
absolutely country music Elizabeth
Holmes yes this did not go the way I
think people thought this would go and
she should be singing country music
[Laughter]
strawberry wine I'm gonna send you this
country music song you'll love it it's
like to me the epitome of like
intoxicating country music great send it
do you have a good time I this is a
halfway mark right no we got to go no
we're done it would be Joe Rogan no I am
I had a great time I find it very easy
to talk to you and this is great I hope
I wasn't like pressuring you to be funny
or divulge any no I mean I'm you know
what I mean I'm also I mean thanks for
asking me to do it I I don't I can't
believe you said yes come on I kind of
asked you I was people hearing this are
gonna think that we're like maybe this
is really our real reaction to each
other I really went when I saw you at
that shows like well she's like you know
in the real comedy world you know it's
great and I'm like but he's like a real
comedy person I'm just like a dinky
stand-up no I feel like I'm like and I
don't mean this in a disparaging way
about myself I just sobs like I'm in
like the weirdo territory of comedy and
well and I'm like I'm like the
mainstream like I'm like the Walmart of
comedy well this is good I'm glad I
remember when I was watching you in
Vancouver I was videoing you and sending
your whole set to Natasha
because of the horse thing hmm
because I had I had a joke about how
it's difficult to pet horses oh yeah you
did I remember thinking avi you love
horses that's so right
no but I was so like I was in she's like
no I know like I got it like I've seen
his show like I was so so I have most of
it all mine I'm gonna release it yeah is
that okay please no that'd be where I
get it out there fred armisen he's going
on tour scheduling it in April yeah
Whitney Cummings always doing live shows
always working work is not a bad thing
and works if you work it works if you
work it you're worth it and yeah and I
have a present for you that I want you
to open when we're done it's gonna be
too loud because the tissue paper oh
we're the same about noise
fred armisen this means so much to me
this means so much to me thank you I'm
so I feel like I want to drive you home
was that the end I like to end really
abruptly
[Music]
you ready what's the final title the
song okay it's gonna be ladies you have
to copy me okay Jesus I was just letting
you have the floor no this is there you
ready okay yeah the reverse song is
ladies okay okay are you ready yeah I
got it it is hard it's a nerve-racking
John try almost you don't want to fail
you know that's the point of it we're
failing that's what we're doing it feels
I feel very prideful in it
um okay your turn now okay uh did you
just make hers up as you went
yeah okay what did you do I don't know
no just carry did you prepare no no I
haven't prepared that's why I was okay
okay you know I I hand wrote down no I
was like you know it sounds good okay
know what I'm saying
I think you're I'm both to know the
ideas and then we don't we say the intro
together this is the intro um all right
you ready
this is a song called River River lady
mm-hmm and we should start it okay
[Music]
Mountains mountains mountain mountains
sometimes on the ocean floor swimming
yes she does yes she does she goes yeah
she does no she doesn't
your song is hard that's a dude you
gotta have plot twists we're not done oh
here she is again
here she is no not you actually know me
pretty well if you know my mind works
watch other corner my eye like you're
able to kind of guess later know the
song it's done so he would cut you off
by now 30 seconds on alright one more
song that was a song all right ready oh
wait am i doing this one are you doing
this one how do you undo one yeah
all right go suit you this song is
called
time Reacher baby in a crib over the
moon okay
yep there
[Applause]
because she was lizard oh it's lizards
lizard yeah like scissor yeah alright
now just do a wrap real quick oh I don't
know that this is appropriation that's a
good boy let's do on my Jamaican Patois
now let's try to talk like Chet Hanks
who's that what Joe Merrick
I mean I can't even it's to him back and
even Knights did you see the DM he sent
Chris can you be Liza Minnelli make up
like what the worst is when you go when
he starts barking at the end or he's
like what is it are that's the part that
I hate the most
she's so ignorant do you know who let
the dogs out is about ugly women
I didn't want to Grammy did you know
that yeah that's what that song is about
think that's shocking
well what did you think it was about
dogs yes literally you got AB is about
rappers the video there's dogs running
around there's a lovely women in the
video but yeah because they couldn't do
that oh they couldn't do that that was
too far yeah can I do a Liza Minnelli
and can you I think so
ok let's see what you got you go first I
don't even know what she sounds like
well this won't work I don't I I could
not pick Liza Minnelli out of a lineup
but Kenny was their name I don't know
her as Neutron Kiki would say she'll
Asha I was I love I love mother told me
I love Broadway and movies and play is
no it's jabs an obvious doodad some
things and it's it's me
barely know that's what she sounds like
about her sounds a little high in octave
do you do lots of impressions let's not
she talks I don't know is it a good
question I passed my chemistry class by
doing share impressions to my teacher
really yeah she loved the Tennessee
school system seems to really have some
very very interesting mine ain't off had
to do work but I think of helped yeah I
think so too
all right I think we got